foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
all right
um
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
good afternoon and welcome to the last
round around 11 of video chess.com
graduates and the women's growth was
2021. we already have the winner in the
women's section but nothing is yet
decided in the open event
yes there are the women's standings uh
and uh later since you're eight and a
half out of ten absolutely magnificent
result from her
and the point and a half clear of the
next player also from China and they
play today
yeah they face each other today then we
also have uh five players on six and
half out of ten who will try to fight
for their prizes and for the Grand Prix
spots right we can come to that later
that's right but there we are those are
the top 10 boards in today's women's
section and Elizabeth Pitts I believe if
she wins she will get her Grandmaster
norm and title let's hope so it's a big
game for her and all the other top
pairings there now these are the current
standings in the open section and we see
alireza out in front by half a point
chased by two players Fabiano and he's
playing today Gregory operand Anna
yeah that would be definitely a very
interesting game of today and also
Fabiana and Gregorio bar and also have
great chances to get this uh one of
these two spots for the candidates but
also we have 11 players on a six and a
half out of ten and these players
potentially can also qualify to the
candidates for example Union at the
moment he has the best tie break and if
he wins and also depending on the other
results but potential he can also be one
of the players that's right and I think
we'll come to some of the scenarios as
well and indeed here we are look who
will qualify for the candidates so um if
all the games end in draws then alireza
of course goes through with Fabiano
uh but as you just said you has a good
tie break if you Yankee wins
he can also get a place with alireza
he has a better book calls and our part
in if he wins he's true isn't he
if opponent beats firusha he also gets
through to the candidates yeah if a
party wins he definitely he's definitely
definitely there
he plays with white pieces so I think he
will try to play for a win because I
think draw doesn't give him this ticket
in any scenario right and of course our
parent and Fabiana could also win in
which case in which case those two would
go through and alireza would not
um various other scenarios here and if
the top two boards are drawn and then
depending what happens on the boards
below
yeah many different scenarios it's
actually very difficult to calculate
everything because uh Buchholz is a very
tricky thing and it depends on how the
players with whom you have played in the
previous rounds will play their games so
during the game the players will
definitely be concentrated on their
games and then they will not go to check
all the other boards and how they're
absolutely how the players with whom
they have played play their games so I
believe we will have many exciting games
today and definitely verified in games
on the top board so I'm not expecting
any any short draws any those are the
pairings Anna indeed look and uh
Alexander bretke for example I mean he's
playing for Kennedy sport if he wins if
he can beat Fabiano caruano with black
he obviously has a chance of getting one
of those two places
so anyone in the six and a half Point
group still theoretically has a chance
don't they
yes some of them have better chances
those who have better buccals of course
but
um yeah I mean once again it's just
impossible to calculate it all right now
but you young you know has a good tie
break for example so yes it has the best
time the best
[Music]
tiebreak is quite high and his tiebreak
is even higher than
uh than like okay he has the best uh out
of those players who are on six and a
half out right then but I think he is
also higher maybe than I think he's just
one point behind Corona yeah but these
are Ty breaks standings can change of
course during the course of today can't
they of course depending on how their
opponents all do so nothing is uh is
sure by any means of course not
um Anna what about voting on today's
games people can still do that first on
the resource correct yeah it's the last
round and the last reminder about voting
you can vote on the result of any game
played in Grand Swiss or women's grocery
just go to to child.com event find the
tournament it's Crossways or women's
Grand Swiss then select the game you
would like to vote on and predict the
result good luck to all of you
absolutely so the players are settling
down arriving at the playing hall now
and Anna I think we'll have a very short
break and then be right back as we say
towards the players as they settle down
and catch the opening of this the last
11th round of the feedhs.com grand Swiss
and women's Grand Swiss so we'll see you
all in a very short time
foreign
[Music]
.com events page has arrived
find all the games from Top tournaments
around the world as well as
championships played right here on
chess.com
support each game and even vote on who
you think will win their matchups review
standings schedules key information and
find links to all the top news
surrounding each event
head to chess.com events today and
experience your favorite tournaments
like never before
yes and welcome back everyone and um
there we see alireza ferocia top Board
of course and uh half a point clear of
the fields
only needs a half point to draw from
today guarantees him one of those two
candidates spots
so big day for him and now and then we
have Fabiano on board two white against
Alexander predka
and uh Fabi also well
it draw be enough it may not be
uh for Fabiana I'm not so sure for for
lerets as you have said yeah if he makes
a draw it's like almost 100 percent he's
he's qualified to the candidates right
because right at the moment his direct
is is just the best so
there is nothing to worry about
so um
we think that Opera will try and try to
win this game I mean it's a it's a the
biggest game of his life I guess yeah
partner will try to win because a party
in style break is not that good I think
he has one of the lower style breaks so
he will try to play for a win
so and then uh all those other games on
six and a half points the players also
theoretically have chances as well to
get one of those two
candidate spots also under the Grand
Prix there's also we think six places
um qualifying places for the for the uh
for the Grand Prix
the open section and
correct
and um I think the Grand Prix has been
announced for Berlin uh three events in
Berlin and uh I think starting from
February of next year
um but
yeah it will be with a new format right
uh with I think 24 players playing
so um Lots at stake and also a high
price money here of course as well
and um so you Yang Yi on board three he
has white against
Maxine vasilograph
also a very big game of course
and it seems like Gregory wants to play
this before I'll do it on my own
shaking hands and the games have
officially started so welcome round 11
and off the go yeah good luck to all the
players I can just imagine how stressful
they are
and when the last round and
so much mistakes E4 on the board
foreign
[Music]
against Alexander right
I think E4 E5 Knight F3 was played in
karana's game and also the same scenario
in grigory operans game against alireza
so two Royal Lopez looks like the other
is going to be five that's right
from Fabiano
and feroza went for the Berlin but
Alexander pratka went for the classical
Royal Lopez
with A6 Fest
and then we see majorly Gregory your
parent has in fact played for D3
Auntie Berlin let's say yeah Bishop C5
which suggests Anna that he's looking
for a more complex
game
66 Queens on the board Bishop C6 they
takes a sex
and now there are many moves I wonder if
these two have played before Anna do we
know if they've played before the
classical game
apparently against firoza I checked I
checked it yesterday and I found only
two Blitz Games actually played in
Internet not even not even all the board
right and they were applied in 2018 and
2020 and it was one one game
apparent one and the one game was won by
alireza okay
oh pardon we saw him win that uh really
quite a spectacular game yesterday with
um Nikita vichugov very interesting game
and Nikita
took chances didn't he he took risks and
ultimately um he paid the price
yeah he played some nice moves like this
Knight E4 which she saw and then he
sacrificed in exchange but it was it was
indeed torrescue and it didn't work out
and um alireza of course won yesterday
against English David Howe
and we spent a lot of time on that game
very sharp middle game and it sort of
began to turn around at one moment
David played this spectacular Queen C6
in the time travel lots of things were
happening
it was uh
that was a big moment in the game
okay here we have Castle on the board
very often white doesn't hire to Castle
and sometimes even go for a long castle
and start the attack on the king's side
but in this game Castle has been played
and the Knight to D7 okay uh also Bishop
D6 is another possibility here but very
often in in this anti-burling line This
Night where we see this natural grouping
upon an already moved there he played
c2c3
Anna
preparing D4 many games have been played
here
I think Castle D4 Bishop D6 right Bishop
5 F6 this is what we can expect
okay
and um how is Port 2 looking at the
moment
oh let's see we have Royal opus
on board two Fabiana played six mode D3
yeah we have seen a lot of these three
and also a lot of games with Eric A1
right
so after D3 uh there is D6 and there is
B5 as the main moves which one will be
played
he has just made a move he's played D6
D6 on the board
CS3
C3 from Fabiano okay so um
Castle
fairly standard so far castles from
Black
and it looks like Knight bd2
yeah sometimes what starts with Knight
bd2 sometimes with rookie was sometimes
it was A3 a lot of also transpositions
possible
should we have a quick recourse at
boards three four five
um
just to check the openings
uh board 3 UND against Maxim we see
neither of six more H3 with H3 made by
E5
so a very big game of course here for
for these two players and um
well Maxim he's also in the frame still
if he can win this game with black
he also has chances isn't he sure
so um a night of Sicilian
okay after yeah after E5 almost all the
night Retreats so I have to try the
Knight B3 and I did tonight might be
three being the most popular I think by
the number of games played
but
but I wouldn't be surprised if you don't
see 9v3 here
Board number four uh
book done Daniel dayak against Andreas
pancon here we have uh Queen schedule
two very young players I know I think
they're both I think Brockton is maybe
20 and
res 19 or something like that two of the
younger players here
I think Wagner is older
I'm not sure okay well anyway how's the
um
so we may see another gaussian after
Bishop before we may see Slough after C6
we may see DTX C4
a lot of possibilities also Bishop
designs of course
an option
all right
but looks like Andrea was a little bit
surprised also C5 yeah we have seen in a
couple of games right we have as well
yes
all right now who's Alexis Cheryl
playing he's playing uh suggestion isn't
he has black against Gabriel suggestion
yeah let's go to that game as well here
we have
about nice the portfolk variation of the
semi-sloff oh Bishop G5
so now it can be Cambridge here after
97.
there are sharp lines after H6 and when
black takes one
also detects C4 right here
Alexa there uh
just sat down we see wearing a tie
very elegantly dressed today it's the
last day that's nice to see
foreign
six and all this crazy stuff
there was a a shop where that he could
have achieved a draw much easier
apparently yesterday allowing white
lying back to Queen
really I didn't check um
Peter pointed it out that the engine had
shown Alexi said he saw it but then he
sort of got a bit confused and
he was
um he was a bit short of time and chose
a different maybe he wanted us to check
his game a little bit longer a little
bit more
and E4 there from Gabriel E34
this game promises to be really exciting
doesn't it this one will be Sharp
and it already indicates that both of
the players are actually ready for some
short play and B5 there from Alexia
five
creation being that's right
quite many years
and after E5 black plays H6
kind of
97. amazing lines possible
and all is just starting here
even not here even like 10 months later
always just starting because it's alone
uh very long and diversary five there we
see from Gabriel
somehow we also even got onto the topic
of the
World Championship matches between Al
yankin and Max over actually over
breakfast
Alexa was uh
wondering I think in the in the rematch
which alkyne won quite easily that they
still played some games after the result
was known that they still played another
four or five games ah nowadays we don't
play yeah nowadays if if it's already
over then okay players you can relax
thanks
I think contractually I suppose they
were
applies to keep playing games even
though I can't already won the match
actually Casper of a natural sure they
also played some
extra games
okay and I think Anna we're going to
move across to Peter himself Peter
Douglas and he has something to show us
Pete just something very quickly was
actually the that shirov could have
played yesterday he did draw the game
and he told us that he actually saw this
idea before in his calculations but he
then forgot about it I'm just showing it
because it's quite pretty
in this position
it's it's tough for a while then he
managed to draw it like 20 moves later
but he could have forced it immediately
by taking on F6 here
if black takes you take a check on A6
so the move of course is King F7
black things now I'm winning because
you're allowing me to Queen right
but no absolutely a stunning move Bishop
to E5
E1 Queen
King B2
and black is helpless against uh
Perpetual this bishop is amazingly
strong queen of six will be next but all
kinds of other checks are in the air and
the engine actually says it's completely
equal because black cannot Escape all
these checks so that would have been a
very nice way to end the game a bit
quicker for Alexa yesterday back to one
hands too
thank you very much indeed Pizza Douglas
there and what a fantastic line huh
you can understand Alexa with two
minutes or so on his clock he told us
that he saw the line and then he just uh
he wasn't quite let's say brave enough
or he slightly forgot that he'd seen it
uh under time pressure there
and shows a different way to play
so um yeah so they have here as we've
said the botanic
system
g596 G5
and Alexa left the board so
um yeah of course 885 will be played
quickly but maybe let's also check the
other games especially um
[Music]
also on six and a half out of ten so for
example Anton gehar against sam7
oh what are the usual opening is three
and A6 and A6 canis me
well so as I understand the idea is that
after C4 black wants to take and the big
five what kind of Queen's Gambit accepts
it
maybe then Bishop B7 but
I am not actually so sure if Bishop E2
and Then followed by
yeah quick A4 okay for you hmm
maybe actually after C4 black is going
to play one more waiting more with of
course he could have sex
interesting E3 A6
not at all a common position
very unusual but it could transpose to
something
um we'll see how white reacts
3 is considered to be a passive approach
yeah your block can your own Bishop
but also quite a solid one yeah you have
a flexible Pawn structure
an A6 from Black
yeah six
good and also David Howell right he's
playing Vincent Kamer I believe
here we have already
it was Bishop G4 and C4 David as White's
here
I think Vincent has won his last three
games
oh really really uh
really hitting form here uh
we saw Vincent's interview
which is the day before
he was quite happy about his win
David of course disappointed um
with his loss yesterday but uh he knows
he's still playing here for a lot today
yeah we told him yesterday during dinner
but he should still fight
so um
let's see how he copes he's picked the
ready opening
he has already played yeah some games
yeah avoiding any big theoretical debate
yeah we also see we also saw his game
against uh yesterday
but C6 is some more
uh popular
approach so Bishop G4 C4 yeah now I
think is six
this may be played but
they take C4 I think is possible Anna as
well isn't it yeah the taxi far as
possible as well of course
and then maybe the Knight E5 or possibly
it's like Knight A3 I'm not sure there's
some gambits there
so alireza uh we remind you is on top
board he has seven and a half points
he's out in front half a point clear of
two players opardin Gregory operon whom
he's playing today
and Fabiano caruana and there we see
alireza yeah let's go back to alaraza's
game what happened after C3 costly at D4
Bishop of the sex Bishop J5 F6 Bishop H4
this thing quite often
lately
all this idea to bring the bishop to g38
and Knight D2
and Knight C4
okay
I'm actually a bit surprised alireza
went for the Berlin
of course it's a solid opening but I
think
he he doesn't have that many game in the
I think he's maybe played this line is
white
um rather than black
two or three times I believe he's played
this
that we are creating we almost touch his
note first the queen E8 yeah I think
it's the main mode in this position
Queen d8 E8
and um
so you're surprised Anna by his choice
of opening
mcfar is surprised but
but say if I had to guess
maybe I would have said that I would
expect the southern or carcon we've seen
several car accounts haven't we heard
from him yes now brilliant I think he
has played
or we had a lot of games there
but he lost in karakan to Fabiano he did
so sometimes you're quite affected or
superstitious you're superstitious
Knight pd2 looks like
developing move of course
keeping the E4 Pawn
supported yeah maybe we'll see some B6
small what does black do with his
Queen's Bishop Anna
blacks Queens Bishop how does black
develop his Queen's Bishop oh okay I'm
expecting B6 and then the bishop goes to
B7 or A6
okay
A5 is also possible
right
I think it will be a long maneuvering
game
actually quite logical because if you go
for a Sharp line and your opponent is
prepared then it's just either Force
draw or you have to deviate and then you
end up even
in a worse position so playing something
like that from White side when you need
a wound is
quite logical
opening choice
right okay so um maybe B6
you're saying Anna to solve the problem
of the developments of this bishop on C8
the Knight will stay on D7
uh let's check what uh
Solomon number 21. how many moves
they've placed here that's incredible
and they just unbelievable
Knight F1 H6 93 B5 it should be three A5
A4 before
six takes
Bishop B6
D5 played
Rook B5 look at that this is this is
nice
rugby five takes and C4 nice little
trick there
Queen D6 8xb5 and Knight E4
and the players they they simply they
just don't spend time they just Blitz it
is this a known position Anna do you
think are they following are the top
games I mean I didn't know about this
idea it would be 5c4 so I don't even
know when uh
like which mall was new here
but um
okay up to here it's uh
it's still more or less normal okay
normal but but then all these
complications with uh starting with D5
and that followed by The Rook B5 Rook
6b5 C4
Queen has to move and then a takes B5
yes maybe we could ask our
uh
production team to help us to check
which more was new
so Queen went to D6
so Queen D6 8X 86b5 Knight to D4 and now
Fabiana is thinking so if y takes on E5
all right let's have a quick look what
would happen
black can take on H3 black can First
Take on C2 and then take on H3
and then the knights is pinned black can
take on wait if black takes on C4
it's a bit risky but maybe it's possible
uh well maybe bishop H3 why not Bishop
takes H3
looks fine
do you have Bishop F4 okay
well maybe at some point uh Queen before
no not exitsu to um
so the white Rook only one will be
undefended
I don't want to you know to try this
night for the bishop unless it's really
necessary
I don't know what about going before
right yeah
yeah looks good looks like a good move
somehow it looks like fabana is not that
happy of uh you think so but of what he
achieved out of the opening maybe he
wanted to surprise his opponent but it
looks like Alexander came really well
prepared what about if white starts with
let's say Bishop B2
and move like that
and if I take and couldn't before you
will be forced to go Rook B1 all right
if Knight takes F3 check
Knight F3 Queen F3 Queen B4 B1
I don't know maybe
um
the thread so I thought about Queen beef
Queen D2
all right just one option here um
this is if I'll be able to play Bishop
B2 in um
in the game position
black has a very powerful knight on D4
what about and if Knight takes Knight
Hannah if white just were to trade
Korean ah or not if Queen D4 Bishop is
three
maybe takes before
so I have two ideas uh like Bishop F4
and Bishop A6 maybe we're missing Bishop
G4 Bishop G4 perhaps
so it's a trick yeah this doesn't work
well it could start with Bishop D2
maybe 94.94 rookie foreign
or Bishop D2 to attack the Apon
interesting
anyway so with Fabi the thinking
what to do maybe he's uh
prepared this far but not but no further
than this
oh he's weighing up different options
what a shame
20 most
so um
you see the logo on his shirt there Anna
looks like a
scooter or
scooter delivery
[Laughter]
nice yeah
I
I don't know it's the first time I see
the slug on his shirt
that is the current position after
Knight C6 to D4 from Alexander predka
bought two game
and Fabiano has seven points out of 10
and his opponent Alexander has six and a
half
so Fabiano would like to
of course he'd like to win it he'd like
to uh
try and win but he's not going to go
crazy
because the draw May in fact still be
enough
yeah Fabiana had a very solid tournament
no losses plus four hmm
all right so we've switched on under to
another game of the top ones
[Music]
here so Knight B3 was chosen we should
be six Bishop E3 Bishop B7 F4
Knight C6 and Queenie two
yeah even I played it was white
have you played the same for white
really yeah a couple of times this
position yeah
and how did you do
uh well were you successful
I didn't have that many games here but
uh yeah I was H3 uh I won some games I
won a couple of games but from the
position we see now from the position
now I uh yeah
we can say
which I won
and then there was one game which I lost
to Katrina lagno
and wrap it okay
so so yeah it's double edged
we need to of course white will Castle
Queen side
yeah white is preparing long Castle then
all these plants was G4
G5 Knight D5 uh black and try to go for
97 95
we saw yangy didn't we uh on the before
the round started going over to talk to
the two Chinese ladies
foreign
in the women's event
so I'm sure they were wishing him luck
as well
Maxime has played a move is it Knight
fd7
trying to bring the Knight to E5 that's
right
so um yep probably castles from White
and then Knight D7 to E5
I think something like um seven eight
years ago this line was extremely
popular but then but then people stopped
playing it
and now we see it again there we see so
Castle Knight E5 I guess
definitely Maxim's favorite opening on
that ce5 I see a firearm against D4 the
night or Sicilian there is also an idea
fire but also Knight C5
and we think Maximus had this position
before
uh in a rapid game
against Peter lecker
I wouldn't be surprised if he had it
more than once more than once because
Maxim has I don't know thousand dollar
games in neither
so it's slightly different to this and
we're not sure but it can be one or 94
or G4
well clearly it's going to be a very
sharp game and you Yankee uh
having missed perhaps an opportunity to
win yesterday
against Alexia although Alexis stood
better didn't he as well in that in that
game yeah in the beginning I think he
wasn't so high I mean the UND wasn't so
happy about his possession also in the
middle game he was in troubles but then
in the end uh yeah his chances to win I
think we couldn't find the defend for
the defense for Alexei in some of the
lines so I believe that maybe his
possession of swinging actually in the
end
and after all it was a direct finally a
draw so um
yeah maybe a fair result at the end of
the day because they've certainly both
had chances at different times
and Alex say playing as we saw earlier
he's playing this very sharp butvinic
defending this sharp line of the
semi-slave we'll have a look at that
game maybe Anna
maybe for this one Board number four
dark against uh
yes Knight to D7 was played
uh Bishop F4 takes E3 Bishop of the six
and Bishop G5 okay everything usually
yeah maybe you will also see Bishop E7
so I spent a Tempo and and blackmail
also black could try Knight B6 as well
here
96 black has to be careful with e45 e45
right
I mean after E4 black and still go
Bishop is seven
I see David how though uh walking around
on camera there
became a scores for him as well today
against Vincent Kamer from Germany
still very classical isn't it and here I
believe Anna white has to move Rook B1
if he wants
oh what was the game
but this is old Theory isn't it yeah
small 15 but
we still have hundreds of games here
that's right Knight if of course is a
move but I think it would be one as well
I don't remember who introduced this
idea
probably Alexa it might have been Alexa
with white no eventually I think it was
early yeah
but back in the 1980s this was very
popular all these lines
so these demos are are the most popular
in this position Knight A4 and Drug B1
and then white tries to play with A3
often
but Alexi a big expert in this in these
systems yeah he's played lots of games
in between the creation
have you played this line for white so
black
uh no
I played something well I can't say
similar but after Bishop G5 I went for
this H6 first and uh another sacrifice
right yes Bishop G3
so yeah Bishop just random different
Mouse at this position I had was black
pieces
but these lines are associated with the
name of michalbovinick world champion of
course I think back in the 1940s Anna he
was analyzing these systems I mean it's
it's a bit crazy to analyze it with the
when you don't have engines and uh to
find all these moves by yourself
that reminds me of the uh of another
line of this well this is not Sicilian
but the polygavsky is still in defense
so I was going to say with the Russian
Grandmaster Lev polyevsky spending weeks
months and years of his life trying to
make this system work
um and uh at least in one of his books
he he goes into great detail about all
his um
efforts to keep the line alive in
various matches candidates matches and
so on where he was sticking
to his guns being loyal to his and the
the opening arm
the defense which Bears his name but
nowadays you put an engine on and it
says playlist
still playable is it
he wasn't the first one who who
introduced uh this Albany and this line
but he was the one who really put a lot
of effort and who developed the line uh
like I would say to new
absolutely and you understand a long
time before of course by the way he's
played Ruby one oh great lovely love it
wonderful I saw note that this may have
been played around about 1981 we think
for the first time we're not sure
brilliant Anna um maybe a good time to
have a quick break
and lots of exciting chefs to come back
to and also have to keep an eye on the
women's games as well let's talk about
these games social break and we'll
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with Club Arenas you can
Club Arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chess variants and with any starting
position you want Club Arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
[Music]
foreign
things to note about this position is
that the white King on H1
yes and welcome back I'm Stuart Conquest
with me on the music and we're here on
day 11 the final day of the feedage
escort.com groundswiss and women's
ground Swiss and we're following the top
games of course and there we are under
some scenarios for what will happen as
regards the qualifying places for the
candidates
so as you know there are seven possible
scenarios and a completely different
people may actually qualify for the
candidates so if all games end in a draw
then fairuz and Karana will be true if
all games are drawn and you wins you has
a really great tie break then of course
firuja and you uh will be I will take
this spot if opinion and Corona draw the
apparent and ferrugia if Oparin and
Karana win then apparent Corona and
there are three another one as well look
at that so if boards wanted to draw and
the white wins the rest of the game then
firuga and Karana if boards wanted to
draw black coins on the other games then
firoz and Japan
and if Russian practical wins and board
from three to seven all draws then
Fairuza and pratke but
um well it's uh I believe uh the
recovery of the scenarios I mean because
these targets and I can't change during
the course of today's rounds can't they
of course yeah um depending on how the
results go so those are the pairings
anyway and all games in progress
as we would expect there uh top ten so
we have alireza ferozan uh seven Hal out
of ten uh two players on 7 out of ten
they are Gregorian Baron and Fabiano
Corona followed by 11 players on six and
a half out of ten that's right and out
of them Union gear has the best tie
break actually I'll write at the moment
his style work is better even than Ty
break right interesting
very interesting yeah this is a game um
also they're playing for um as we
mentioned earlier Grand Prix places as
well as prize money of course this is a
very sharp but theoretical line
um in Alexi shirov's game he has black
hair against Gabrielle sardisian
and he did in fact Gabriel played this
Rook B1 move Anna yeah he played the
rugby one and we have got updates that
it was uh ulman who played it for the
first time right many years ago
interesting
um group B1 and then uh
foreign
so uh we think Alexa has had this
position something like 18 or 19 times
in his career so um
and he mainly played it from black side
from the black side maybe he even tried
it was white but I remember many of his
games fire on boards fire I'm sure
that's because I think that book has a
whole chapter on just on this variation
now I think if it's the first volume
um
and all his lengthy analysis and uh game
after game trying to establish the truth
of this crazy variation
so um it'll be uh very interesting to
see how this game develops
Bishop takes F1 there and nobody there
no not the boards look at that
wow
um we we ought to also just have a quick
look on at the women's games although we
know that we have a clear winner already
in that section
yeah in this game I think uh we can
expect Queen D5 or kin F1 or maybe some
some new move
uh but I think we Define F1 are the main
ones in this position and let's take a
look at some of the women's games
this is the top board Azure genre
against late engineer it was uh relapse
with the bishop CFI without before and
we've seen a lot Bishop C5 uh but it's a
bit different because after Bishop C5
there's additional option like after C3
B5 to go Bishop C2 right
so a D5 a very sharp line uh D4 all this
I applied myself with white it takes E4
Knight to B to D2
just a second Knight B to D2 is the move
I don't actually
remember uh my I myself play
E5
not 65 here yeah
okay Knight D2 it takes F3 Queen F3
at Bishop D6
Queen takes Bishop D7 Queen F3 it takes
the four oh okay I remember um there
were some games like that and tonight E4
played
right and there this is the position at
the moment
so um
we already have a winner as we've said
many times now um
late thing she has already won the
tournament she's qualified for the
candidates
and later she had sorry um her opponents
usually now she's got a gym no mercy
didn't she by by winning her game
against Layla who scored the gym
and we should also keep an eye on Lizzy
Petty's game because she is playing
We Believe for the GM title today if she
were to win
uh Lizzy's playing board number three
against bibisara Survivor who also
scored a GM Norm yesterday uh here is
their game there we see them on camera
so it's kind of a grandfold
yeah oh this we have seen okay this
tournament it's three a five the five
night before
uh I think even uh well something
similar happened in the game of bibisara
a few rounds ago against none of that
needs them but uh
they're with the Queens on the board uh
were actually a white blood Queen City
to earlier so Bishop of one Knight C5 uh
Bishop E3 was the last move played we
played all right at least the current
position okay
uh baby Sarah having a great tournament
here GM norm and I think she's gaining
like around 30 points in this tournament
yeah exceptionally good result from her
and Lizzy also has played a really good
tournament but um she would daily love
to win today the last round
if she can
so plenty to play for
he has spent much more time than her
opponent
she just played all these moves
relatively fast yeah she spent only six
minutes to get here
um and maybe
and how is them and how's your sister
Maria doing today who's she playing
today uh she's playing against harakar
so it's uh quite a serious match
yeah we see Maria on the left
and
which openly do they choose
four nights four nights with D4 we
should be four takes takes Bishop D3 D5
it takes the five castle castle Bishop
G4 Modern Line
at night it is not the main move here I
usually f3s
right was played
um C takes D5 sc4 and I see hurricane
spent quite a lot of time on her move
Rook E8 but it's quite a logical one
Queen C2 H6 and now Maria spent a lot of
time to play H3 okay
and this is the current position
by the way and I can see from the
smaller board on our screen that Fabiano
did Play Bishop B2
in his game
okay maybe let's switch to the open
section and
Fabiano
against Alexander predka
it's worth three for us uh so here yeah
Bishop has been played
all right one of the moves we discussed
so will we see Knight F3 and queen
before
yeah good question if knight uh if
Knight takes F3 Queen takes F3
Queen B4 is met by Rook B1
so um
that's one possibility
it's Knight takes E5 a threat now or
Rook takes C5 it probably is
I think Knight X5 is well yeah
it does right now
so which other options would
black half
this bishop between maybe a new move for
Alexander because all the moves up to 94
he simply blitzed them
and this was the first time in Corona
started thinking and he spent like
uh 28 minutes to play before just on
that move goodness me it's a long time
we spent five seconds together smooth
but of course I guess whether you're
commentating it's just an easy thing to
do you may go back if something goes
wrong but the players they don't have
this option
and I should be to
let's have a look again another Swift
Knight takes F3 check
becauseback doesn't need to play Queen
before here but it does uh
Force white truck to because after would
be one the queen has to move again you
said maybe Queen D2 after that
bone structure is better yeah
so this A5 Pawn doesn't become weak also
if I was a Target
uh if black plays something like 97 then
I think just Knight E4 right position is
better yeah it looks quite nice so white
I agree
so maybe we need to be
fast with B1 looks like the only move
now Bishop you fire the threat
um I think so yes right
so um
what go back to Queen's Queen just we
have a look at Queen D2 your move
not so sure about Queen D2 but maybe
it's okay
if Queen D1
right and white we could just trade
just trade Queens
and uh some advantages you think for
white
and push E4
if that works
solve its problems
so let's say take take and E4
a bishop F6 we have it xd3
right
because it's very important to somehow
break this chain
that's how I feel it
that's why I have to play Queen D1 after
Queen D2 I know it's just one of the
suggestions
for like let's say take stakes and black
doesn't play E4 then white plays Bishop
A3 or K1 and starts asking questions
about this A5 ball yes
hmm
okay
also Bishop takes D1 I suppose is
possible instead looks a bit odd
so that E4 maybe doesn't work anymore
because of Bishop takes F6
but then what Rook d8 do you think
I also think about 97 and Knight C5
right
yeah because Rook d8y could then play
Bishop C2 and E4 still doesn't work
because the bishop takes F6 then we see
Alexander pretzka
it seems like a long time ago and it was
when he played that fantastic Queen
sacrifice didn't he yeah in around two
or three a wonderful game
in the white side of the king's Indian
after black played Knight into G4
but uh well there he is on board one um
sorry board two in the last round
playing Fabiano
anything happening in alirez this game
man on board one
since we lost something must be
happening well but I'm in any moves
have we missed okay A5 uh we are one of
the most I suggested B6 or A5 uh Queen
to C2 uh Queen F7
so there will be no let's see four
that's four okay uh Bishop G3 a typical
move in this position and A4
B3 right
so that's where we are
so what we may expect here so white
wants to play Knight C4 I suppose
uh maybe Knight C4 yeah sometimes C4
it's a move like B52 weakening
yeah I'm also thinking about B5 B5 if
you can
I'm thinking of David house game against
uh
Allegra yesterday of course a completely
different position but he also played uh
like this on the queen side
what would happen after B5 do you think
some space
I'm thinking about C4 hmm c3c4 yes
also nobody's there yeah
okay
to his game
and the last move played Anna in this
game was
B3 b2b3
so um
looks like Knight C4 is
why it's next move
okay maybe also B6
if um if Knight C4 then Bishop A6 if C4
we may think about C5
but usually black goes for B5 in this
setups right
okay
because he can't play Knight B6 because
the E5 Pawn then will be uh
short of one Defender
and so we'll think about B6 or B5 here
and if Knight C4 after B6 on it as you
say then Bishop A6
is
[Music]
okay
Fabiana is checking
how about Alexa shoot off in that
hypotophinic variation of the semi-sloff
uh here you have your Bishop defy uh
Queen D5 sorry was played it was played
uh Bishop E7 was
was also played
and white takes back on E7
yeah white just now look there we are F
takes E7
back to play
I'm curious if Alexei had had games in
this position from here
well I think you may have done
instantly moving there Alex is so still
well within his
knowledge Bishop F1 to D3
it's move number 20 but the long
theoretical line
in fact I'm saying that he even played
this line um
last month on the Spanish Team
Championships
exactly this position I believe so
wonderful against whom against uh I
think kusupa Fury of
so um
simply following his own game
Bishop F1 to D3
white Supply just leaving that work on I
mean it's impossible so unless one knows
these these variations
and has already studied them so I
couldn't find any of these moves really
should write take take
if check only eight black has Knight B8
very important
and um
lots of pieces hanging here Knight on C3
will come B1 Rook on d8
yeah you can't play it without
preparation no exactly and especially if
your opponent is prepared to you or not
so he's an absolute specialist in this
whole variation Alexis Sheriff
I wonder if he expected to get this
today I wonder if it was part of his
preparations if he looked
at any of these lines
this morning
and if Gabrielle has come to the game
with a certain idea in mind a certain um
plot twists as you said yesterday
any new ideas
to improve on on Alexi's existing games
in this variation
I mean surely Gabriel has made since
Alex even played this last month
Gabriel must have um looked at those
games
and have something in mind
yeah quite often such sharp variations
are actually all analyzed until more or
less a draw
until the first time control sometimes
we've seen new moves after move 40
occasionally
in sort of extreme cases
so maybe some Knight E4 here
it may be that he's playing this for the
first time this whole bottomic variation
uh Gabrielle
goodbye I actually don't know
I remember my Galaxy's game but I don't
remember that would be amazing to me to
play this for the first time in one's
life against Alexei of all people who is
sort of the perhaps the biggest expert
in history on this whole system
Knight to E4 has had been played
no no children play it so we are here
even The Rook hasn't been taken
maybe a knight E4 here
immediately
it's hard not to take a rook with Czech
isn't it with the pole like that I mean
but white has this option of
like instead
fire but I remember that Queen D5 is one
of the main moves
so it takes takes Bishop D3 and this is
the position
so now we have taken the rock we have
Knight E4
okay
well maybe we'll just have to wait and
come back to this game because it's so
um it's so crazy crazy and Alexi clearly
within his uh
comfort zone I would say I mean uh
playing all this
quickly
yeah maybe let's check Anton's game uh
what happened there after A6
uh Bishop this Rios played Bishop G4 C4
takes it there's actually exactly the
same position with the pawn on A7 that's
very odd that white lost The Temper
though
so E6
Castle C5 detects five oh I just tried
to go for a nine game
no that's uh not very ambitious I think
it's all from my from wet
big surprise to me that he played Bishop
D3 there just losing a tempo
voluntarily
but let's say in this position if not to
go into the end game then were to
suggest black will take on D4
otherwise
so I did xc5 if black takes and taken on
C5 back all right should be shouldn't be
okay for black
sure it's like
Queen's Gambit accepted well that's
right with I think with an extra move
almost
with the bishop on G4 which is fine yeah
well not the most exciting game so far
is it for us to look at but we're
keeping on it we will um
see what happens here and David David
Hall David Howell uh
okay against Vincent camera from Germany
opening
he's six takes takes uh Bishop F3 then
very solid for black C takes D5 it's
actually very important because after
that's not a good move is it Queen A4
check and oh dear that does win a piece
bish124 drops uh sometimes black takes
also with the e-pawn right
Knight C6
and it looks like exchange love that's
right black traded a live score Bishop
for the night
uh which is actually quite okay so
Bishop E7 is three Castle uh Bishop D2
Knight A5 I could even expect some
maneuver like 96 96 which is quite
typical for this position
uh but Knight A5 and B3 okay keep the
Knight off from C4
yeah on the other hand we can use the
square so for example after Rook C8 Rook
C1 may be the problem
there may be the problem with Bishop S3
okay
yeah but also very very even positioned
very calm
and David has used more time
than his opponents no surprise I won't
be surprised to see that
but a long way to go of course
and one more game
we're on six and a half points
did the game were
we saw a bishop D6 Bishop G5 now H6 has
been played A6
C5 also kind of
kind of Queens can be accepted but this
time with the isolated Pawn on D4
Knight on D7 is a bit misplaced yeah yes
I would prefer to have it on 67 before
and then on D5 but we can still get it
right try to get into D5 uh I'm also
expecting to see Bishop Bishop is seven
at some moment maybe
even now maybe after Castle
or okay B6 Bishops developing yeah okay
this game can of course Catch Fire I
mean uh I say the Queen's Pawn positions
plenty of active chances for the
for the wide player here so we see how
the game develops and
um also we invite questions I think we
try to maybe have some questions from
viewers if we have time to uh
to take the most interesting questions
and uh of course keep up to date with
all the action we're going to have a
quick break Anna okay and then we I
think come back to alirez's game and
fabiana's game that's right and fighting
for two spots in the candidates so we'll
see you all again or learn how to
improve join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
hundreds of thousands of people playing
at any moment you'll quickly find a game
with someone at your level whether
you're a total beginner or a Grandmaster
you can play games at any Pace against
friends other members or one of our many
computer personalities
chess.com makes improving fun and easy
sharpen your game with tactics puzzers
and enhance your strategy with our
videos and lessons by top Masters learn
from your own games with chess.com's
easy to use analysis tool regardless of
your skill level chess.com has all you
need to take your game to the next level
chess.com is your go-to source for chess
News live coverage of tournaments events
and everything in between
experiencechess.com anytime and anywhere
whether you're at home on your computer
or on the go with our mobile apps
signing up is free and easy so what are
you waiting for join chess.com today
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Championship is far more intense because
you can't really afford to make a
mistake or let your guard down
pressure and the stress of the match is
the most difficult part everything is
challenging it's non-stop just that you
go from thinking about the game to
playing the game to thinking about the
next game it's definitely going to be
enormously difficult match for both of
them
[Music]
okay yeah
and welcome back everyone it's the last
round of feedages.com garage West and
women's grounds West 2021 I'm here with
current Master Stuart conquest and we
are accommodating on the last round of
of this tournament so let us remind you
about the possible scenarios right
absolutely very important who will
qualify for the candidates indeed well
if all the games end in drawers or the
top games that is then furusia and
karuana go through
I'll erase it with half Point advantage
of course over um Fabiano if all games
are drawn in new wins then for you can
actually qualify with furusia ahead of
Fabiano
his because at the moment is better than
fabianos or parking can of course
qualify if he wins and Fabiano draws
then those two so I'll probably go
through with furusia
and uh also Opana can qualify with
karuana if they both win and Anna
there's other possibilities as well of
course
yeah there's also many other
possibilities but once again it's quite
difficult to calculate all these
possibilities because it depends not
only on the results of the top boards
but also on the results of the players
with whom the players who are going to
qualify has played right so it's really
very complicated
so um yeah
so this is uh the top board game Anna um
we see that alireza took on D4 in fact
um so he didn't play B5 or B6 he played
E64
he took questions some time before
taking on D4 then Bishop D6 was played
uh C takes D6 and the question will I
take with the pawn or with the Knight
94. it is paid Knight 64.
it's also
I guess
absolutely yeah both both look fine
so Knight takes D4 so potentially the D6
Pawn can become a weakness
yeah if white brains like the rock 31
that's right
so black to play still he has to develop
his C8 Bishop
white man wish to play f2f4runner as
well now he's moved his Knight
no do you think
yeah that's possible
no maybe Knight C5 here
right
that looks uh very sensible Knight C5
and well maybe uh maybe F4
think about F5 after F4
okay yeah
another possibility is Knight B6
repairing D5 I think
that also makes sense and once again
after F4 now we have two options D5 and
fr
y also Knight B6 stops the Knight Knight
C4 there's a Alexa updates Alex's game
so maybe let's see what's happening
there they're just blitzing out their
moves Anna are they going to repeat the
moves
I think coming to B5 really
I would say it's actually a bit
surprising from the right side a
handshake look handshake now what's
Alexa following his own game from last
month
I think possibly he was
from a matter of weeks ago in fact in
the Spanish top division
team championship and look uh maybe they
were asked to yeah to make all
maybe they hadn't made 30 moves 30 moves
yeah
so that the Arbiters don't have to check
if it's a repetition but I also think
they have repeated more than three times
and there we have confirmation two kings
in the middle of the board the game is
over and um
yeah to draw I would say Alexa had a
really good tournament with many
fighting games some excellent wins yes I
think he's uh he should be quite happy
about his results oh I'm sure he is yeah
and he'll win a good prize here he also
maybe Anna has options I'm not sure for
a Grand Prix place
that may come down to the question of
tiebreak I don't know yeah right at the
moment his Starbucks is quite far high
before this round like he was third
among among players who are on six and
half out of ten so yeah great result I
would say good results I like this
earlier was it in round one or two where
he sacrificed tonight in the Sicilian
yeah 95 95 that's right wonderful
sacrifice
uh he's fought hard and um also case
when our event side was uh that's right
black pieces
so plus three I think for him
um yeah very good result and he also as
we've said before and um he was the last
player to take up a place in this event
um just the day before the tournament
started I think he was asked if he
wanted to
to take that place and uh indeed he did
and he's had a good tournament good
result for him so well done
Riga born and Brett Alexa
he's home his hometown that's right
his hometown
and there's um alireza yet to move
let's also quickly say Anna talking of
recap that is today uh the birthday of
Aaron nimsovich and who was also born
here in Riga
Lottery of course so um he died quite
young I think he was only 48 when he
when he died
1935 or so I think uh yeah I know that
he died when he was young but I don't
know like I think he was just 48 years
old I believe in Copenhagen he died but
anyway a very important figure in in
chess history and in the developments of
the game and the modern game
his name is still that's right
and some other variations as well
and of course he wrote a couple of
classic uh chess books
so his birthday today as well
right so alirez it's a move he hasn't
moved yet
yeah I think we may expect 96 in this
game uh let's maybe check Fabiano's game
if there are updates
now there are no Bishop B2
and uh
I think Alexander has been thinking for
more than half an hour already or nearly
half an hour it's a bit surprising isn't
it really because
okay it's one of the critical points and
it's already number 21. 22 actually
so he may
he may afford doing that he blitzed all
the moves
up to Knight D4 and he started thinking
only after Bishop
I would say amazing opening preparation
especially considering the fact that the
last book move
like according to the theory was so long
ago right
so yeah great preparation by by
Alexander what was this move Rook P5
already known this idea of Rook B5 and
C4 that we saw earlier this little
tactic is cycle
but both of the players
applied it to her course very fast yeah
probably five and uh also the follow-up
the following moves
all right so
um okay so we spoke about yeah Knight F3
and Bishop before idea yeah Queen before
idea
and um what can we say about Alexander
bretke also Anna because um although
he's been up among the leaders hasn't he
more or less
from the early rounds
and uh
very strong play I mean he's two six six
eight rating we can see there
for me I mean I hardly knew his name
before this event to be honest yeah
but um
okay he's relatively young right we have
had a couple of uh inter resource him
here
where he talked about his games
and how he feels here in noriga
but um
well one of the biggest games also for
him in his career I'm sure
on the biggest
to have a chance still if he wins of
getting to the candidates
but um
okay we'll come back to this game of
course
uh any updates in Anton's game
oh there are yeah Queen D1 has been
played by Rook D1 Bishop C5 A3
Castle before Bishop E7 and Bishop B2
all right so far it's a very quiet
start to the game yeah though I think
that Blackheart
yeah black hasn't quite a good black
cousins yeah possession a nice safe
position for black
so I think Sam Serbian who has black
he'll be uh
quite satisfied and A5 just played their
Runner looks like
yeah F5 with B5 I think we are bringing
the Knight to D7 and then to C5 or V6
right if not then good questions for how
white is going to protect them before
right
I'm expecting a draw in this game
okay
at the moment what about he's playing
against uh over before that we have now
um Milan over two for our first
interview of the day yes we do the final
day at the Grand space in the first
interview of the day is with Grand
Master Alexis Shiro finishes your game
with Gabriel sergacian and it was a draw
in the South defense line you're very
familiar with how was it for you to play
this game
uh well okay you know there a lot can be
taught
about what inigulation and since I still
played it's hard for me to reveal any
secrets although there are practically
no secrets in that variation anymore but
uh all I can say is that okay white has
some
opportunities maybe to
to try for win in those lines but always
if he really tries it takes its law to
some risks so my opponent went for a
very I would say
safe continuation if you can say these
words about continuation that involves
the sacrifice of two Rooks so it was
clear that my opponent did not mind to
make a draw in this game and okay when
you're black normally you are you don't
mind it either I mean you
know on this level if you are black you
can start thinking about win only around
move 2030 if something happens before
but so so I'm I'm fine with my result
and with my game so when you're an
expert in a line and you're fully
familiar with it and you've played so
many games in that line how difficult is
it not to rush during the game during
those opening moves and always
well first of all
I mean he didn't rush either so okay
what can I say I mean
I
so actually I was walking around looking
at other games because the position I
was familiar with
and then okay there are some some places
where you can choose at least so so at
least you have to think I mean what
might expect you in every line that you
choose so
so
the tournament is now over for you 11
rounds when you look back at the 11
games
what are the highlights which were the
most interesting games for you
personally
well I don't think I can highlight any
games because
I cannot be really satisfied with the
level of my play for example starting
from round six I was a Muslim defensive
side The Only Exception was yesterday
when I was clearly better and but still
the position was too complicated for me
and time was also running and then I
just misplayed everything and should
probably have lost
so so at the end I had to be happy to
draw although if you look at the
position I had around move 25 30 of
course I would not be happy with the
draw but what I want to say is from
round six to round 11 this was the only
opportunity where I could really think
about winning the game so that means
that actually my level is below that
level on the higher
part of the tournament so I can be happy
that I didn't lose any game at the end
and from first part one unexpectedly
became one of the leaders well okay
uh this sacrifice of the exchange
against alternations in the end game was
very interesting but I still haven't
checked with the computer so I don't
know how strong it was but when I
sacrificed the exchange my feeling was
that it was involving certain risks but
uh at the same time
I thought that if I don't do it then I
should probably just repeat the position
so
okay so that was yeah okay the game room
second round was quite interesting too I
mean I sacrificed the piece then it was
full of mutual mistakes but at least it
was an interesting game so
okay all together I can be satisfied of
course with my performance I want some
ratings so but uh but okay it's
now I have to wait until the tournament
is over to see if I am qualified for
Video Grand Prix or not so let me ask
you just about that you were one of the
leaders in this tournament here and you
stand serious chances to qualify for the
feeder Grand Prix if you do you will be
one well first of all about the future
Grand Prix I only launched yesterday
shortly before paying so that's
something about says something about
video communication right uh
we don't talk more about that I think
okay and which I think is
is totally abnormal I mean all those
roles I think okay I only have chances
let's say to be in top two which I
thought was a bit unrealistic or I
simply want to have okay good
performance so I thought uh I'm only
playing for one of those two things and
about Video Grand Prix suddenly
yesterday during the dinner my teammate
David Anton just told me this but he
himself only learned it maybe two days
before so okay so this is video
communication okay so good review to
mention I'm sure Fida will and should
take note and if if you go to the Grand
Prix and all together looking at this
tournament as well I don't talk about
ifs I mean if I'm qualified for Grand
Prix I can answer that question before
it makes no sense okay but overall we
can conclude that this was a good
enjoyful tournament for you
well okay no I don't think there was
anything to enjoy but uh at least
I'm I'm happy with my result okay well
at least you're happy about something
thank you so much and congratulations
yeah okay thank you
yes and thank you Milan and Alexis here
over there who um indeed
he drew his game and undefeated Anna in
this tournament and uh seven points out
of 11. so um
I made a very good performance from him
let's let's be fair yeah so let's wait
if he will get one of this Grand Prix
spots right
okay
um there we see alireza with the black
pieces and we could just check in on
that position Anna please to see uh if
we've missed anything
he took on B3 instead
I am not sure about this 8xb3 because it
feels like black has a bit more space
here and black attack at any point right
so that's why I didn't want but maybe
alireza wanted to simplify the position
to trade one pawn and one pair of Rook
is about to make his next move and D5
okay maybe he just want to simplify
everything and he's played D5 you see
and make a draw
very concrete move
uh what's the difference if he played D5
immediately without shopping yeah
good question
obviously not to keep pressure and a
very good question
maybe something like uh a move like
rookie D1 to keep these Rooks on
but then we get the open file yeah but
uh how much value that is for black I
don't know maybe he thought that I could
move his Rook away for e6d5 followed by
Rook at D1
decided
how many ticks
and why it's a play
so basically back is saying okay you
have the a file but it's it's not really
of any immediate advantage to why to
have this uh this Quest
maybe we can expect it takes D5 Queen D5
and let's say Knight to C4
okay
yeah but the position is uh is quite
equal
seems to be
seems to be yes
so maybe alorazo was right
with his all the decisions to simplify
starting with etax D4 hmm
yeah okay well um
we assumed that he wouldn't have
anything against to draw Anna are you
ready sir yeah if he draws this game
then it's like
almost hundred percent he'll qualified
and I think it's the most important
thing for him right at the moment
not the rating points and everything
with the draw I mean no with the draw
he's he's definitely uh got a candidates
please uh by the way yesterday I checked
the live ratings and he jumped towards
number four once again after winning
this game yesterday
but I think he doesn't care about it so
much as about qualifying to the
candidate absolutely yeah
he would be ready to be world number
five even world number six or seven but
just give me the right to play the story
and only 18 years old um so uh huge
achievement for him
and uh well so far we think he's doing
fine
sort of a level position and he has
simplified it he's dropped the Rooks and
he's played D5
now how is Maxime doing against you
young here
um I was going to ask you Anna in this
night off this could be one of the
sharper games
of the day among the top players
uh sorry one Rook C8 now uh now Queen S3
are very logically because Roxy 3 was a
positional threat of exchange vaccine
they're about to make a move it seems
Castle G4 K8 94 Queen A5 A3 B5 Knight F5
so um Mike seemed to play
he absolutely has to win and it doesn't
need to have a chance of getting one of
those two
candidate spots
I would say
but also you and gear will try to play
for a Wednesday they're both playing for
everyone
and eventually I didn't draw it as it
usually happens when most players play
forward
well of course it's too far from a draw
here but sometimes that happens so
Knights of five so the D6 Pawn is uh
under
attack
but that may not
be the most important
thing let's see how much is in place
it's always a question if
it's good to take on F5 or not very
often it's not good to take on F5
because then we completely lose the
control over the D5 square and also
after it takes a five before he's
privacy oh it's not weak anymore so
before played right
and it's getting really sharp very sharp
indeed
if 86b4 Queen will
take back you can text back and
defending D6 by the way
and uh well many things can happen here
I like this game
you like this game I like this game yeah
I like this I like this game
I wonder what white should play there
maybe uh Rook D4
very complex
which suits both players doesn't it as
you say
Maxim has a lot of experience in all
these structures and he really feels
these positions very well
they must have played many many times
these two
um no I don't think that many no no not
that many and I don't remember any games
in the last few years
because I think you and GI he didn't
play any of these online events right
Maxim did
um I remember that the World Cup 2000
18 or 19.
uh I think
Maxine won against you and Gita in I
don't know which Rod but okay but he won
so he hasn't taken on B4 yet has he
okay but after B4
or maybe he's considering to take on E7
and 95 or 95 immediately is it possible
95 immediately yes maybe it is
hmm
could be actually
you could play this way
sorry Bishop takes D5 Rook D5 are going
to A4
right
and then if B3 Queen takes A3
I'm not so sure
a bit strange with black screen on A3
there
might lose it it could be trapped if
there was no Queen on E3 area
maybe safer would be Queen C7 instead of
Queen A4
yeah why not
threaten Queen C2 and B takes the three
I completely Amazed by Queen
C7 and then um
then I don't know then I like Black's
position
I wonder
what's going on yeah well white defense
C2 Rook H2 Maybe
and the black tanks
either Queen 683 or maybe B2 to B3 I
don't know
sharp stuff
okay this will be a very interesting
game
uh maybe let's check
how Fabiano
right
other oh that's all oh the queen came to
D2 Queen came to D2 We are happy to see
Queen under two right
we're happy to see it
because we had it on detail already we
are happy to see it again
so
um of course the bishopon C2 is attacked
anuis discussed Queen D1 didn't we here
yes we spoke about Queen D1 and all this
idea that if Queen the one or the one
may be four
what else if Queen to E2 is it more or
less the same Queen takes takes E4
I think it's good for black I mean let's
have a look Queenie too
E4 Bishop F6 it takes D3
yeah of course white doesn't have to
take an F6
oh then I take
you don't think right
and how what do we think the white is uh
White has no Advantage here really
it's um
it doesn't look like anything
is there any way I can keep the Queens
on after Queen D2
as well as these moves um
Exchange in Queens what else
okay four looks strange
the one
looks strange strange Rook C1 also looks
strange how the Roxy one looks uh maybe
a less strange
but if I start pushing the pawn A4 if A3
yeah
let's see one you could play A4
and the bishop takes E5 oh no I can't
say I can't of course I can't start the
Bishop defensive Rook
of course I can't
maybe Knight F1 would be a possibility
Rook c1a4 Knight F1 Queen A5
right
or even
the queen before
it does look a bit strange Rook C1
so um maybe you're right Anna maybe
white should offer an exchange of Queens
here
what did you think about Queen D1 Queen
61 Bishop takes D1
I think we stopped analyzing after
Bishop D1
I spoke about 97 here this move uh
right
sure okay could happen
before
Bishop E5 Bishop C4
okay
yeah Bishop before Bishop F6 Bishop D3
I will be three check
both players have more or less used
exactly the same amount of time to reach
this position
Yeah well black has nice active pieces
actually
doesn't look bad at all
yeah I'm preparing 97.95 and once again
E4 may be possible Rook d8
it does look at so bad for black
but the problem and as you said before
with Rook takes D1 then there was the
possibility of E4 for black
yeah with the bishop on C2 I have the
opportunity to take on this three after
Bishop F6 right so the bishop is
attacked it was not possible with the
bishop on D1
that's right okay this looks very good
here we take on F6 on the next move and
then before very pleasant to plug
absolutely
okay
so um
Fabiana to play after
Alexander's Queen
to D2 Queen before Rook B1 and queen D2
annoying white a bit religious by
attacking the C2 Bishop yeah so this is
the current position
and Alexander getting up from the board
so which other games should we do David
Hall could we maybe just quickly check
on David
I found this game uh dark against
yesterday panko okay yeah a few more
skeleton played castle castle and Quinto
season he decided to unpin this way
right
Bishop B3 but Queen on C7 you know 261
the queen has to move somewhere again
I likewise came here
I actually
I've heard some Bishop E7 or I play B6
after D5 I have E5
right okay but um yeah maybe he wasn't
happy with that
or Knight B6 than Bishop B7
and uh can we click on check on Davis
game please and I just quickly and then
we'll have a break I think
and not a great deal happening
he managed to push
then Queen B1 preparing Rook to C1
try to you know try to use this bishop
pair advantage of course the position is
quite closed and it's not that easy
right but yeah there are we know lines
from the cattle on here and where it
gets a bishop power and also this
magical Pawn structure and uh well it's
it's not uh it's not a dead draw no no
of course not and it could be a long
game in fact
that their style eight hours at least
good um all right thanks uh Anna for
that so we'll be right back in a couple
of very short minutes with all the
action especially of course the top
games from the open so we'll see you in
the new chess.com events page has
arrived
find all the games from Top tournaments
around the world as well as
championships played right here on
chess.com
sport each game and even vote on who you
think will win their matchups
review standings schedules key
information and find links to all the
top news surrounding each event
us.com events today and experience your
favorite tournaments like never before
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome welcome everyone this is the
speed chess championship finals going
down here with Carlson and Nakamura
the bullet portion comes to an end
hikaranakamura is mathematically
eliminated in his chances and the bottom
line is Magnus Carlson shows why he is
the Magnus Carlson
it has been hikaru's speech test
championship this 2018 and Wesley so had
an amazing event this year as well and
we were tied heading into bullet before
akaranakamura separated himself in the
final portion
the blunders is rook and it's just
things are just not going well for
Wesley they traded back and forth
Landing heavy blows but ultimately the
heavyweight matchup is going to go
towards akaranakamura's favor
hey Cara will be winning his third in a
row extremely impressive display once he
actually faced a deficit he has looked
like the best a car we've seen
[Music]
three
yes and welcome back and the speed Chess
Championship
um starting tomorrow Anna Monday
November the 8th and uh first match up
giri against Duda any predictions
uh no I don't know what to expect in
this match I know that the devs of
course a very good Blitz player a very
good online let's player but uh well
gear is also very strong
um chess.com speed test championships
with I believe a hundred thousand dollar
prize fund there so um lots to look
forward to uh and as we say that first
match up tomorrow
meanwhile here in uh Riga Latvia we have
Fabiano here hasn't moved yet Queen D2
came from Alexander predica and Fabi to
play
Lots at stake
um so he has been thinking a lot he has
already 20 minutes or so
another important decision
we've been looking at maybe Queen D1 or
possibly Queen E2
but um we'll have to wait now alireza
Felicia on top board
he's playing a Gregorio parin
and that is the current position
yeah he has a clear plan to trade
everything right everything he sees
so we saw after D5 Anna the last
position and a few more exchanges yeah
takes Queen takes D5 Knight C4 95.
right
quite a safe position very safe from
black I agree
I agree
and um
yeah if other is a draws if you were to
draw this game that guarantees him
a place in the uh in the candidates very
likely no well I think he's a half a
point ahead already
that would give him eight points
yeah sure so he would get that
guarantees him a candidates please
and at the very least to share our first
tier
in the tournament so you can see why
he's happy to uh
play solidly exchange trades and pieces
and um
what could white try what about the move
like Knight E3 Anna
trying to keep more pieces on the board
but uh
already many of them have been tried it
so maybe just queen queen
there is absolutely no weakness no
weakness that's right
and um
yeah black has a safe
safe position and the pawn structure is
uh
the same on both sides
both kings are safe of course
white has this open a file but what does
one do with it it's not really anything
any advantage from from having that
[Music]
to try to get a better night or the
bishop but still
they're quite difficult quite difficult
to improve the position okay
so at the moment we think uh alireza is
on course
to uh
to get one of the two candidates places
and then Fabiano is sort of the next
favorite I suppose
also you yangi if he was a bit Maxim
in that sharp night off game then you
Yankee would have also very good chances
to get that second place
and yeah
so before the last more we saw
but uh but would you see Maxim on his
own at the board there has few Yankee
now made a move
good question I know now now we've got
some updates so 97 a rook is seven eight
is before Queen before and queen D4
played oh right Queen D4
all right yeah also I spoke about this
match at the feeder World Cup 2019 and
actually Maxim beat Union with a score
of 4-2
and it was a third place match right
in 2019 that was okay
24 so black does have this weak points
on D6 and A6 as well
so white house for what it's worth the
bishop pair
so he's saying okay happy to swap queens
and
try to hit those weaknesses
and of course White's king would then be
safe once the Queens are exchanged
yeah white will definitely be happy to
to trade the Queens because then the
king is safe and all these weaknesses
and Bishop power
and black would try to keep the Queens
on the board
but how to do that that's right yeah
I mean if for example Queen
A5 and maybe just Queen takes D6 is it
possible
I wonder
it's a bit dangerous it's just a bit
dangerous yeah Queen D6 Rooks history
we might check it
and then um
Anna if B takes C3 and what's happening
then yeah bit xc3 should be played
does black have something here
and black has something here
something but what
hmm
okay many ideas like
Queen A2 and Knight F3 is threatening
checkmate
oh Mike seems to play the move though
look
I'm not sure
let's see he's played Queen F5 there you
go
right so um yeah we understand why he's
not
happy to exchange Queens Queen A5 black
keeps his attacking options
and um
prepared to sacrifice the D6 Pawn of
course
you try something safer for white like
Knight D5
right
maybe just rookie eight drop the root
back
or do you think black should take
immediately
I am considering boss options so I don't
know it's it's not easy to say
now immediately what should we applied
rookie it
and um
yeah this could this could certainly
happen
a very clear position very unclear
not sure if black threatens anything at
the moment
maybe even uh Bishop D2 Anna
if I wanted to try to
burn the bishop to C3 or you just want
to well just ask the queen where she's
going you know
another movie
um
I was going to say Rook H2 with a knight
F3 is a problem so not Rick H2
o is quite large
there we have a few of the playing Hall
and I can see
David Hall on the right
set up his boards
that's David
it seems like Europe added his game
against Levon aronian right
and it seems to be a draw okay
yeah there may be some other results as
well I know that if
that have happened already some some
draws perhaps
but anyway certainly levon's game there
is Overlook and um we think he's drawn
yeah not so many just uh
three more draws
all there are all the other games are
still in progress
so the one Ariana I think he expected he
wanted to have a better tournament
uh though in the end he won he won
yesterday he won the day before
yesterday so I think these two wins
improved his mood
but yet he didn't fight for the Canyons
no that's true yeah I think he came here
to actually
um try to get one of the tickets but of
course yeah he lost a couple of games
and then he was not in
Queen D1 uh it looks like
Fabiana who's played Anna
Queen F3 D1
which we also spoke about
playing all our moves
just a bit slower than us
back to play
okay black doesn't really have options I
think black has to take
I mean it would be very strange when the
diploma with like Queen G5
my sister I think
oh that game is a server
a draw there between Maria and harika
bought two
and how do you think Maria feels about
this tournament about her results here
fairly effectively I'll just say I don't
know well she's not disappointed
of course she wanted to win and to
guarantee her a spot by winning this
tournament
on the other hand I think her chances to
get to the candidates by by the writing
spot increased
after this event right okay so that's uh
it's good for her
yes I was just saying is there any
argument at all in favor of a move from
black such as Queen G5
keeping the Queens on it looks uh
well
but do we need to keep the greens on the
board
just wondering if Alexandra is trying to
win this position maybe uh
he could consider such a myth
it's a bit strange I mean it feels
strange to bring the queen there
maybe Queen E1 attacking A5 and 85 right
after Queen E1 maybe you have Bishop
before okay Bishop C3 in the worst case
no I think black should take
on D1 right
okay
uh we've got a message that delays uh
playing some interesting game they think
she yeah letting here on the top board
all right
so there we see the two Chinese players
in the women's section on board one
let's check what what's happening there
so this is the top board
in the women's event
hmm
why so
so 94 uh
takes takes Bishop E6 I'm not sure if
black should take only four
Bishop G5 yes good move
Queen to C8 C takes D4 uh the problem is
that black Cannon Castle because the
Checkmate that's right
so at six Bishop D2 C6
Arctic C1 Queen D7
yeah and blackhead to do something with
the King
soak in f8 we should be three takes
takes Rook E8
you chose to check my channel if black
had canceled
instead of planking f8 so everyone can
follow if castles of course at any point
oh then of course Greenwich don't miss
that it's checkmate
that's why she's put a king on a fit
age she's ready to sacrifice two Pawns
I mean after Queenie it
and all these traits if she wants to
play Candy
and maybe Roxy it trying to bring her up
to situ right if Bishop says Trisha has
before
hmm
all right yeah quite quite logical
decision maybe psychologically for her
as well and not not the easiest game to
play because one because she's playing
her compatriot and two she's already won
the tournament she's got the candidates
players she's won first prize
so she's played a perfect event of
course she doesn't want to lose today
but um it'll be interesting to see how
how she manages and Elizabeth I think is
doing quite well Elizabeth Pitts
playing for a GM norm and even title we
think
oh she's winning
she's a pawn up
and it looks absolutely weird
it was a Pawn on C6
right yeah
she does indeed seem to be doing very
well
something went wrong for black
yes um
some months ago
okay it's already
looks better for what
before text takes Knight A4
and B5 could black stop
B5
probably not difficult so
yeah 95 it's it's not possible you take
okay so what happens so maybe
simply six Rook D7 no it takes F6 and 95
played
check this is close
to her GM Norm
and maybe it's the last one
I think it may well be the last one yeah
and her opponent already made her gymnom
yesterday
um if I'm not mistaken
yeah actually I don't think she knew
actually I heard that Bibi Sala didn't
know that she was playing for the GM
so I came as a real
surprise and a very welcome surprise of
course
I feel that Liz is a bit nervous
and I am surely to know that if she wins
she's getting dinner
so um also if she wins she can be second
or third
right it's a very important game for her
no she's had a very good solvent
and what she described it as the
tournament of her life didn't she uh in
an interview that she gave some some
rounds ago no
but um she lost one game didn't she
uh to my sister yeah to your sister to
Maria that's right
but she's doing very well here and every
chance of winning this game
maybe let's just show check one more
game in the women's section it's Olga
badelka against
Daisy Corey right Daisy is also on six
and a half out of ten
and so she's uh she's got an amazing
sequence of five consecutive wins I
believe Daisy having lost the first
three
and how are they doing here anna I
thought it looks like her wife's
position is much more pleasant
all these weaknesses on C4 and B3 the
Knight can come there
and then just F3
is this the current position yeah it's
the current position I
I really prefer white here
so I don't know maybe just maybe I
should take the night off with a bishop
but it's watching that's why it's moved
I'm sorry
well then yeah Knight C4 so threat in F3
suddenly the Knight is trapped well it's
very awkward for black
that's right it's very difficult and
also time
isn't on her side no
okay okay
so let's refresh no updates in the game
of Fabiana Karana so Queenie one was the
last mode Alexander is still thinking
okay
let's take a look
Knight E5 and Knight B6 was played Queen
28 and Knight C8 Queen to see it as well
but this is just
a very drawish but true
not when it's at all well I mean uh I
think uh alirez has done what he set out
to do he's neutralized
any white advantage and he's played safe
he's played solidly and traded some
pieces
and he shouldn't really have too much to
fear
from
this position
and Maxim's game
right he played Queen A5
and that's it and that's it
you young
hasn't moved yet Queen B4 to A5
we looked at a little bit we looked
quickly at Knight D5
we also check between this sort of look
to Queen D6 and Rook C3 we weren't sure
that what was happening
maybe a different move maybe bishop D2
immediately but then Knights yeah that's
three areas 95 looks safe doesn't it
looks uh a natural move
I think Bishop did too lose this on the
spot wait
um maybe not
no but I agree it doesn't agree it
doesn't look good at all no so 95 I mean
just Knight f300 accessory
sure
there is of course Queen a format
it's another story
what do you think you'll do here
I don't know if you find something after
Queen D6 uh
so uh Rook CS3 hmm
maybe he takes on E7 can he
yeah
looks very dangerous
and more or queen ahead it's not a
Checkmate
no then the white will be checkmated
somehow yeah
there's this and maybe just
taken on B2
or even Bishop B3 here or something like
that or Bishop B3 here
highly dangerous yeah
shouldn't work
possibly b63 here xc3 also looks
very dangerous
okay
let's have one more look at them if we
take C3 what would blackplate just
rookie eight
or something
um
sharper
so if you give a check and then Knight
F3 uh there is Queen to B4 right
right also Queen BH check is possible
isn't it
right and then bring and then the queen
and then there's just yeah
so yeah this is a checkmate
but if not
and uh this is still a checkmate
oh it's still Checkmate very nice check
that's nice
actually I can made very nice so Knight
F3 doesn't work
your first check Candito Knight F3 then
the camera so eight two three
so it looks rather good for white to me
at this at this point uh and if we play
a rookie8 or the idea of frog B8 sure
yeah rookie it's here
I don't like it so much for white I
would prefer to be black
a queen D6 has been played he's played
26 wow
Fearless man Brave man Fearless
absolutely Fearless
Queen takes D6 he had safe options we
thought about 95 but he's really
testing Maxime here
I think he's
thinking
and Maxim takes is a player ID off there
Korean Mason
well let's go back to B6 C3 rookie 8 I
don't think we uh
we we just started looking at it didn't
we really
but that's where we want
we want end
analysis because it looks uh too good
for black
you think it's really good I said let's
see it B take C3
and rookie eight
now what could I do here
what could white play
King C1 maybe ready to get off the um B
file
but do you like it for what well
at least quintess history
hmm
no I'm not sure I do like it
um okay after takes the three other any
other moves or not really
what did we say about quintix E7 did we
reject it because there's no it doesn't
look right now I know you thought it's a
Checkmate for for a while but we didn't
see how exactly so we spoke about maybe
this idea right it just looks completely
wrong for me doesn't it
doesn't look good there was also
also Bishop B3 and things like that here
yeah
yeah so I think he has to um take on C3
and I didn't see what else he could do
I see that Fabian who's taken on D1 with
his Bishop by the way
in the other top game okay
probably because of your idea of Rook
takes D1 E4
going to run Bishop the one and then uh
we suggested Bishop before
right
and then black meets Bishop takes E5
with Bishop takes C4
okay let's go to this crazy game
yeah it's more exciting
anything else that Maxim could be
thinking of apart from riptics night
yeah I'm
I'm also wondering uh well if he plays
Ciroc to E8 maybe this is another option
all right
preparing the sacrifice and now if white
goes 95 right
95 allows some night
C4
what's wrong with 95
seems okay
I mean Rook text C3 must be critical
don't you think
Roxy 3 looks very interesting
thematics Sicilian exchange sacrifice
for black
tens of thousands of games in chess
history where black plays Rook C8 takes
Knight on C3 after white is
especially Vice Castle queenside
yeah it doesn't work here because I
don't have a rook date idea
right
and we think if B takes C3 then black
would then play rookie eight
and uh Alexander pratka played Bishop
before
good you published before hey you played
your move
Bishop f8 to be for protecting the A5
pawn and a nice active Square for his
Bishop
and he's not worried about Bishop takes
E5
Anna we're gonna have a quick break uh
just a couple of minutes yeah let's have
a quick one because I want to see this
game and then we'll be right back we're
also following the action just as you
all are as well so we'll see you all in
a couple of very short minutes
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Championship is far more intense because
you can't really afford to make a
mistake or let your guard down
pressure and the stress of the match is
the most difficult part everything is
challenging it's non-stop just that you
go from thinking about the game to
playing the game to thinking about the
next game it's definitely going to be
enormously difficult match for both of
them
[Music]
and to welcome back everyone for the
last round of Feed the chess.com Grand
Swiss at the women's growth Swiss I have
Grandmaster Anna mozuchuk here with The
Grandmaster Stuart conquest and we are
really excited about the games which we
have today and let us remind you about
the possible scenarios of who can
qualify to the candidates still so well
I mean as you can see on your screens if
all the top games end in drawers then
Ali reservous and Fabiano Carolina will
go through to the candidates the four
games are drawn but if you yangi wins
then firusha and you will go through on
current standings anyway on those tie
breaks and Oparin can of course win and
go through as well
uh and uh Fabiano has his Destiny in his
hands doesn't he because if he wins he's
definitely got a place
and various other combinations are
possible there as well including if
Alexander predka wins
then he could also go through so um
so the top of the keyboards are
extremely extremely interesting
absolutely and we see a really fighting
chat in those uh in those games
and uh for example this one all right
E28 was played
so you didn't take on C3 he didn't take
on C3 why
why indeed
what about Bishop E5
Bishop takes E5 here with well I didn't
think of at all
but okay obviously now if Knight takes
C5 Queen d8 check
yeah this was ends the game
actually or queen B8 no Queen
yeah I think just uh
just this is a checkmate
he has played a move uh it looks like
he's played 95 Anna
Circ E8 and 95 so
once again can I just go back because
this moment is so interesting a Roxy
three
maybe bishop takes e51
oh
look at that Droid
top board game is over half half Joe
agreed it was a level position
and um well
Anna how does that affect the standings
yes and that means that alireza firoza
is qualified to the candidates
congratulations huge congratulations to
earlierism which he deserved as well
it's still not clear if he will be the
winner of this tournament that's true
Fabiano wins and uh there may be uh
but uh yeah he
he will definitely play in The Academy
golden ticket to the candidates at just
18 years of age one place
so the other players including of course
Fabiano are playing for the remaining
candidates place but uh
but but now I think it's easier to play
for Fabiano so he already knows the
result of that game okay uh and even if
he makes a draw uh he shouldn't worry
that maybe a parent wins and so okay
this is true this is true so maybe
you're right yeah
um of course he'll be keeping an eye on
your youngest game with uh
Maxim
could be you were right under the bishop
dick C5 was the uh the key to the
position here if Maxim had taken on C3
can I just check when I took in C1 does
it lead anywhere
seems not to huh
it seems not to yeah the problem is that
Queen on D6 is protecting the rock only
one and I don't have all these ideas was
that
I thought about Queen A1 followed by
roxy2 then Bishop B3 but white simply
takes and eye contact
yeah so maybe we should be five
interesting
it's a vaccine played rookie 8 and 95
and quite fast you only played Knight C3
to D5
yeah but now roxy3 was a threat Maybe
yeah sure
surely yeah if
white played some other move then air
accessory was coming
95.
blocking
this diagonal and queen atom of correct
well Precious on Maxim now
pressure we we had that in the video
there Fabiano talking about pressure
earlier
and you couldn't be more pressure
related than this playing for a
candidate's spot and the last round of
course
P5 from the from a Chinese player
and what can you expect now
maybe Anna he also wants to play moves
like Queen takes A6 next
so if Rook C6 so just to check
we have Queen A3
we have a queen before safe options
right you have sales options here and
you have unsafe options many of them 97
is unsafe option
right
but as you say queen back quick Queen B4
for example looks very safe
yeah it also looks good
it looks good if the queen has to go to
d8 it does look good the attack looks
less
strong
so let's see what Maxim comes up with
here
can he try to sacrifice on situa take
take and wow root takes C2 what about
Queen 2 A4 King six
check
hmm
I wonder kindy too
King D2
and then what queen six E4 to play
with a big mess
yeah it's so easy to sacrifice pieces
when you're analyzing
if something doesn't work okay we go
back we suggest something else
Rook takes you to King taxi to Queen A4
check
other animals in between so for example
after oxy 2
can take C2 is of course critical but
maybe maybe you have something else like
Queen A6 uh Milan I believe you now have
an interview ready for us so over to
Milan thank you Anna Steve yes with us
again
11 rounds 11 days yeah Grand Swiss is
over for you and you're the winner
congratulations you just threw your game
and with it you won the tournament how
do you feel right now
um it feels great and it's a very long
tournament it was very long tournament
um
first I came here I I saw that my
chances are very young though because
the players are very experienced here
and I didn't see myself as a really big
con okay rating voice I was Contender
but in general these tournaments are
very tricky and I am happy that it it
ended very well
how difficult was it for you to play
this game psychologically I mean because
obviously you're in the lead you just
needed a draw to secure your Victory
your opponent had white pieces and he
was playing the game of his life
obviously sure so how difficult was it
for you to focus on it oh and normally
many people would
like lose here in the last round or it's
it's a very tricky situation and for me
luckily they're almost 100 percent
qualified so I had this in mind and
in general I think the most important
game of the tournament was yesterday
that was very important to this fight
against David is very difficult pairing
because he won many games and he was in
shape but today I was pretty confident
and he was also
not uh going all in because of the Grand
Prix qualification I guess
we're all looking at all 11 games how
how tough was this
yeah it was going very smooth and
I had very comfortable positions until
the Fabiano game and after the Fabiano
game it was getting very upsetting
because I had a good position out of
opening and I managed to lose that game
but okay and then I
and luckily won this in the next game so
then that was very difficult these two
days three days and which do you think
was
um probably
against David probably because it was
very very sharpened yeah
so
we have a lot of questions issues is
this ever gonna work out in the end yes
how was it seeing all your many of your
chess colleagues and friends after a
long time obviously you are more used to
now playing online and seeing people yes
it feels great it's too many of them I
didn't see for two three years so it
feels great and I'm very happy the
tournament ended because
many were saying that tournament might
not end but the organization did their
best and the tournament finally ended so
it was that was a good news
so our beginners in chess or have
someone who they want to introduce to
chess what would be your message to
those people to those people who are
just starting out in chess and I'm
looking at you know this Tournament of
games here and looking to towards you as
you know the winner and and probably as
their hero so what would be your message
to them
um yeah I think like chess for me is
always a game I cannot never quit I
believe and it says it's very it's
when you learn chess it's finished I
think you should go all the way and even
if you are not professional you will
every day you will think about just
so it's a very very nice game I think
and it's very good for mental health I
think everything is great and this this
coins Gambit I believe they are showing
some things
but I believe in general chess players
are very intelligent and very
disciplined
who is when you're looking for history
of Chess who is your favorite chess
player
um I don't know I'd try I always said I
try to learn from all these 16 world
champions
they're all great I think
and but in general for me there is no
difference
um
how will you celebrate your victory
I don't know I'm going to
home and we will say
thank you
questions or anything bad
oh you just joined all the greetings
yeah and congratulations
well done thank you
thank you very much
thank you Milan and alireza uh they're
giving us an interview and of course
he's absolutely delighted
as
um as anyone would be I mean he's
qualified for the candidates
and he's played brilliant chess here he
said yesterday's game with David was
maybe the critical game having lost to
Fabiano
um yesterday's game was absolutely
critical and he came through he won that
game
and there was also one more highlight
chess for me is the game I will never
quit I think these words were strong
um you also mentioned the Queen's Gambit
there as well didn't he um of course the
Netflix series
and I think he said the chess players
are intelligent and this nice nice words
we're not about to disagree with that
and um well talking of discipline Knight
to five there that's the current
position between uh you Yang Yi and
Maxim
critical moments here
the board 3 game and ruptake C2 and it's
a move that you come up with
yeah we are not sure if that works or
not but it looked interesting like Rook
C2 you can see two queen A4 was the
light we considered but here we are with
another interview and here we have
Elizabeth pets who just scored her GM
Normand I believe it would be a title
for Elizabeth finally congratulations to
Elizabeth and our test third two
millencer thank you Anna yes we have
Elizabeth pets with us who just scored a
victory against baby
and with it you secured and send your
final GM Norm so
you said the other day that this was a
tournament of your life when I
interviewed you a few days ago do you
still stick by that is this the
tournament
um yes with this outcome of course I
will stick to that because I believe I
never
started in such a way of course when I
lost to Maria I became a little bit like
insecure or shaky because okay it was in
a way a crucial game because the draw
would have secured me also the norm but
actually my main aim was here not to
score any Norms but to qualify for the
Grand Prix this was basically like the
top priority and for this reason today I
didn't want to take any risk in the
opening because I saw like I will just
check what harika Maria is doing and if
Corey has winning chances because then a
draw might have been also enough for the
Grand Prix qualification
so now you're obviously you achieved
what you set out to achieve when you
look back at the 11 games you've played
uh you said which was the toughest but
which was the most beautiful game for
you this time
oh that's a tough question actually I
think the most interesting one for sure
was
um The Rook ending against Leila because
it was
um well kind of how to say in English
and let me think uh it was like
something you can actually teach to your
pupils because it was about activity and
like the underestimation about like
material where's this activity and I
think this was a game which I liked very
much from this point of view but apart
from that actually I don't remember like
whether my games were so special here
not I guess I I didn't do too much
mistakes so maybe this was the key of
success I don't know
and overall how was it being in this
isolated bubble for 11 days for you was
it obviously you played well so it might
have had a positive impact oh well
actually like for me to to stay in a
bubbles no problem because anyway I'm
not the type to to go out or to to to to
to party around and besides it's winter
and uh it's anyway cold outside so I was
quite happy with staying in the bubble I
could stream
um Netflix and Prime with my mobile
phone it was great so I mean like I had
my movies in the evening and I had great
company my boyfriend was here then also
shanzai like one of my best friends she
was mainly joining me in the evening so
we'll be hanging out a lot and I guess
like I felt quite well
okay so what is now next for you what
will you be focusing on
um well in three days the European team
championship starts and I guess like the
majority of girls will have to play it
and I underline have to
um because it will be super tough like
after after these 11 games it's not only
like that it takes a lot of energy but
also the emotions the nerves and
everything take a lot of your reserves
so I hope I will be fine in like three
days to go on for the next tournament
and is that
yes I think you asked me the question a
couple of days ago and I would still
stick to that you have to study a lot
you have to prepare a lot and of course
like what I forgot back this a few days
ago is that you have to keep your
emotions and your nerves together and
like for example like a game like today
means everything if you win you score
it's a tournament of your life if you
lose you want to basically die somewhere
alone in your room or if you're okay
with a draw it would have been more or
less neutral but I mean sometimes to
have a single game which actually
changes like from happiness into sadness
in such a drastical way is actually
quite nerve-taking well obviously it
ended well for you so congratulations
once again thank you
and good luck in the European
may I say something at the end I would
like just to thank my coach because like
um he had to Bear a lot with me and he
had to really like be resistance to my
moods and to my
um Nerf fracking behavior and therefore
Yannick merciful
I'm sure he's he'll appreciate this a
lot thank you once again thank you
yes and thank you Milan and big
congratulations uh Elizabeth
scoring her final GM norm and title and
uh well
brilliant brilliant
news for her and absolutely deserved and
she won that critical game here today uh
just a few minutes ago and uh
yeah yeah and of course I'm also happy
about it because Liz is my friend and I
was rooting for her in this event so
beside that she has chances to even be
second I think if things goes right but
second third yeah she'll be one and
qualify for the Grand Prix as well
qualifying for the grand priest yeah
good result
um okay so uh now Maxime has played a
move it's interesting um Anna he's
played uh Queen A4
Andrew cage too and Rook it's two
already played very fast
clearly for attacking C2 of course
um as well as E4
has
very quickly replied with Rook H1 to H2
so what can we say what about
this E4 Pawn
you mean if Queen takes you for what's
happening yeah sure
maybe rookie two
yeah rocket 2 looks good
and then um something happening on E5
some problems
rookie 2 looks uh simple and strong
and if not Queen F4 what else do you
have
uh let's assume Knight E7 is not the
thread because it looks too dangerous
yeah like the stakes on E7 and queen I
took window one taken on B2 it's Knight
F3 possible and the Knights of three to
D4
93 attacks The Rook on H2 if I play a
rook F2 you still want to play well 94
or
or maybe something else
maybe just Rook after 94 Queen to B4
maybe after we have two the knights
could be left on F3
as well I don't know if there's other
moves there for black
because the C2 Pawn is still um in the
air then
he's played a move
a maxim
Maxim took something maybe bishop D5
yeah he's taken the Knight
all right so clearly e takes D5 is not
possible because of the bishop F4 is
hanging
[Music]
I have to be a little bit careful that
the queen is not trapped there
and we were like a Roxy sex Queen A3
then
Queen to E4
or queen A4 immediately Queenie for now
is it better an hour after Roxy sex and
I think after roxy6 do you have any
other moves besides Queen A3 I don't
really see because when the queen moves
then we take and we're also taking the
rock that was my point right
I'm sorry if this you just take
hmm this somehow doesn't look so great
for I agree okay so maybe Queen 65 has
to be played quintax D5 looks safe
defense E4
yeah it's the most natural move isn't it
Queen 65.
let's try to guess what Maxim is
preparing here
maybe Knight F6
uh Queen D4
no 24 I would take a knight F3
don't do that
let's have six maybe um
Queen A2 or queen B3
not sure which one
if we take on e4 after
but either way black can play Queen
takes E4
yeah seems uh
not bad for black in fact and queen B7
is it too far
Queen B7
looks a bit uh
looks a bit strange
maybe I agree I also feel that uh it may
be wrong
although maybe your right was going to
be three
although okay let's make this strange
move
right
Queen B7
could be okay actually
if Knight takes E4 then Bishop takes E5
and there are updates Elizabeth pets
became the
38th female player to earn to get the GM
title
right in history in history
so who was the very first you know the
very first
woman to achieve the GM title uh no no
no I believe yeah
who's been in the news recently
hasn't she because of the Queen's Gambit
uh yeah she's
they put wrong information about her
they said that she has never faced uh
male opponents but actually she played
many tournaments against male opponents
and even against the strongest male
opponents like world champions and
sometimes she was even successful so it
was
it was not true what was said in the
movie
so um
yeah well her lawyers are demanding
quite a large sum of money I think five
minutes or something like that
but uh
Netflix not surprisingly are contesting
that
not handing over the money
okay straight away
how this case by the way you I suppose
you played her as well many times and
not many I think only once
okay uh yeah many years ago there was a
round robin tournament where I played
against no no
so um okay let's uh
oh by the way there's some something
happened in Carolina's game we could
maybe have a quick look at that Anna
before we come back Knight F6 was played
in uh 96.5 all right so this is what we
expected
and Karana
Bishop before Bishop F3 and E4
okay
before Bishop C4
is Alexander's idea
so if takes takes takes ticks
after Bishop's secretary's Bishop D3
so is it all leading to massive
simplifications
and another draw
E4 from Alexander here
he just wants to break up while it's
Pawn chain here by getting his Bishop to
C4
okay white has to take with the Knight
or maybe bishop E2 can be possible
can I do that well
technique sticks and Knight D7 or Rook
d8 this looks good for black it does
look absolutely fine for black
so maybe white has to take on e4
but then how to avoid ticks Bishop takes
C4
and really looks absolutely fine for
back doesn't it
as you say on the F Bishop C6 then black
has a bishop takes D3 very important
and black as a pawn up
but otherwise
[Music]
there doesn't seem to be much danger for
black Hero at all
maybe even some danger for what maybe
for white a little bit
a little bit yeah this past a pawn could
be a
Thorn In White sight
maybe Rook C1 here on a rook C1
and black takes
okay on the black and play for a win
this white chicks on C7 yeah but this
spawn is more dangerous than this one
right yes
hmm
maybe uh well fabiologists maybe has to
steer this game to to a draw and
hope that that's uh going to be enough
for that second candidate spot yeah
because I I believe like here it looks
like he doesn't really have any winning
chances and I really like uh what
Alexander pratka did oh well we are
going for a short break just a couple of
minutes and we will be back with ups.com
events page has arrived
find all the games from Top tournaments
around the world as well as
championships played right here on
chess.com
each game and even vote on who you think
will win their matchups review standings
schedules key information and find links
to all the top news surrounding each
event
head to chess.com events today and
experience your favorite tournaments
like never before
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone to here we are the
last day day 11 round 11 the last round
of the feed hs.com Grand Swiss and
women's groundswiss I'm Stuart Conquest
here with me on the music and we're
taking you through all the action and of
course the results who will qualify Anna
for the candidates well we know one
person we already know one person is
who had a great tournament here and yes
he is already qualified to the
candidates but the second spot is not
clear yet that's right Fabiano has a
half a point lead
but if he doesn't win today then he
could be caught and then it might come
down to Tire break for example
we're here to beat Maxine vashiragraf
could get that second candidate's spot
so of course it depends on the results
and those games
are very much in progress and then we
see Fabiano playing Alexander predica
and we think Anna that the position is
more or less level
he played DTX E4 not Knight takes E4 so
he preferred to keep more pieces on the
board still after Bishop C4 it's a big
question what he's going to do can he
try some Knight F5 or E5 E5 I believe
can be dangerous for white
I don't know yet oh
what would happen after E5
after if I know I just saw that
Alexander made the move and yeah it was
Bishop C4 no surprises so if E5
uh what can happen now
so if Knight D7 white has Bishop c66
although
well that is quite awkward in fact yes
or if Knight D5 right
Rook D1 or Rook C1 X1 Bishop B3
taken C7
would you take that pawn
I'm not sure yeah and it may be very
dangerous for white
we are speaking about this lion
takes on D5 this may actually end
badly for a while it doesn't look right
at all for what is it
doesn't look right at all but he could
start with Rook C1 and then not take on
D5
but the problem is this A5 Pawn this
past a pawn for black is going to be
really dangerous
[Music]
five Knight of five
wow that's also thought about Roxy one
before and maybe E5 now okay he
explained E5
so uh what can happen if Knight D7 if 97
I think Bishop CS6
it looks uh this looks powerful Bishop
C6 oh that looks strange for black to go
under voluntarily uh sure
so 95 looks much more logical
so um book C1 looks natural
D1 or Rook D1
right okay
and if black were to move his night
night
you can't be Knight C3 can he
I don't think I'm not sure but uh
takes takes work C1 maybe he can play
Knight F4
after Rook D4 has 93.
let's have a look at that Knight F4 94
there is still a bishop C6
or Bishop C6 after D4 Knight D3 maybe
this even also Knight B6 and or after
Rook D1 is possible isn't it might be
the safest move
and Knight B6 here yeah
at this point I mean just to
cover some squares defend the bishop
stops Rook D7 Rook B8 let's say
and then just yeah push it
he's played I think Knight D5 Knight A4
another thread
uh he has played
it has played I don't know what but very
likely Knight D5 yeah 95. right okay
I think you're right Rook D1 makes a lot
of sense
yeah then actually 96 was a nice one
okay
white has to be very careful with this
spawn yes
no absolutely well Bishop C6 here makes
sense doesn't it Bishop C6 he is
rook p8 and now black wants to push his
a pawn
or as you say Knight A4
there's also um
looking quite good
could be better for black couldn't it
I like the Box position
even in the worst case if you lose both
of these pawns and win this one then
still quite a big chances to make a draw
but uh I don't even see
how white can I achieve that
so um actually this one may be dangerous
for white there were some scenarios that
have uh of course now changed
um because we know that ferus should
Drew with our parent on top board
so um alireza has that first
place and if Fabiano draws
as long as you doesn't when you're young
you then we think he's out in front on
the tie bricks
but some
nothing is certain
but of course if Fabiano loses then he's
out then he definitely doesn't get the
place
I think that's right
so um
he needs to take some care
that's the current position not yet the
bishop The Rook is still on D5 and 195.
but you know at the same time I wouldn't
say that this position is so safe for
forward
clock time's about 35 minutes remaining
for Fabiano and 18 or 19 for Alexander
they played quite a lot of moves under
30 or so
29 yeah 29 moves right
so um
shouldn't really be any time
issues for either player nothing too
serious
we're thinking of Rook D1 if Rook C1
then black can play Bishop B3 which
controls the D1 Square
also can black play Knight B6 after
Rook C1
of course it's better to do it after
Rook D1 but still after oxy1 this is an
option
and then Bishop D4 maybe then Bishop B5
Bishop D4
trying to um
take on C7
okay I can simply maybe take take and
play 97 if Rook B7 there's Rook be it
I'm a bit worried about White's position
here right because of this apron now the
positive
Alexander getting up there from the
table
all right he does still have options
doesn't he if he were to win this game
of getting that kind of displays himself
depending on the other results
meanwhile has Maxim
yeah let's have a look let's check this
very sharp game with you young here
Maxim there
so Queen B3 you're a move uh Queen E4
Bishop takes E5 quintax E5 Eric E2
this is where they are
so what should be a bit better here I
think
white is going to trade the Rooks
one pair of Rook on the next move
uh is that E4 possible or not
so ah 94 here I didn't think about that
Maybe
can we play
Queen D5 is a virus came off to make
after 25 maybe when Queen B8 oh that's
fine let's take a look at this
is it possible big threat
yeah the thread nice is three if white
takes only four I want to play Arab d8
everything family
Knight C3
so maybe not Queen D5
and if we take C4 here on it what
happens
Erwin at the end ah in the end I
mentioned the fructicks I think it comes
to the eights Rook 88 and that also
picks up the exchange at least
well wins material yeah I think white
has to take and then take on A6
um
yeah well clearly this is right track
check and queen A5 I made the check on
A5 yeah
foreign
hmm
he's played
it looked like he played 94.
did he
I'm not sure
924 threatens Rook B8 I guess yeah 94. 8
or even Knight C3 check is the threat
oh sorry no his friend should be it
rugby to check yeah
so uh Queen D5 we just had a quick look
at
which other moves does White have
if Bishop G2 then Knight C3 check
I mean while dark
against yesterday Panther right so they
made a draw they made a draw it's a
board number four both players were on
six and a half out of ten so now they
move to 7 out of 11. uh but they are out
of the competition for the Canada sport
they still they still may have they get
the ground that's right
and what about Anton Anton against uh
seven uh these players are also on six
and a half out of ten
something was played something happened
and we saw you young he sort of played a
move and he kept his seemed to me kept
his hand on the piece
um couldn't even released it
he played Queen D5
so while we say queen B8 or
what are the other moves
I think going for an end game is bad for
black
Bishop is definitely more powerful than
the Knight here and also why all you
have uh has passports also the pawn on
A6 is weak I I like
it yeah
what about if white yeah what could I do
apart from I mean how does he do with
Knight C3 check he also Rook d8 is a
threat
foreign
fact
okay Queen B3 I don't think we should
consider that
well
maybe a rook D3 hey maybe think you
could be three I'll just repeat
this looks so risky
Rook D3
it does look risky yeah okay nice three
doesn't work at least something
nice history we can take it yeah right
there's also Queen F4
um I like Queen F4 queen of four yeah
maybe a queen of fine
black has a
various threats here and open lines and
the Knight 24 is
is causing some trouble for weight
what about Bishop Jitter
Bishop G2 here okay
maybe Queen F4 doesn't really help it is
possible you're right Bishop Q2 yes
so again after analysis through horror
accessory
it somehow looks shaky for white isn't
it but maybe
also instead instead for our Queen ba
there is for example Queen cs7 with a
similar idea but of course I prefer
Queen B8 because it's writing in Knight
to six right
so um white happy to exchange queens and
black almost certainly
I'm happy to exchange queens and he'll
keep
keep his attacking chances Alive by
moving his Queen
okay new idea
idea Queen B8 and after this three
the new idea is this idea but it's it's
also
well all the pieces starts to hang after
rookie five so I'm not so sure if I was
good okay or something yeah
Queen before then at least we can
consolidate with Rook C2 E8
right
there's maximum screen a very short game
yes clock time for about 25 minutes for
white 20 for black
and um
tense moments this
can you check David's game David Hall
David Howell yeah please let's have a
look
oh wow look at that okay here we go
Queen A2 where was it before oh okay it
was on A1 and queen A2 how to evaluate
this position
two works for Queen and Paul I think
it's equal
the engines they usually prefer to play
with the queen but uh but then they
don't see how to
actually make progress and there is no
way to make progress so
I think we will have a draw in this game
right okay I wonder how did they reach
this um
and I just quickly
this material um okay we saw this
structure yeah
so if I was played Black was first to
change
the structure and then Knight E4
takes text Rook D1 F5
Knight on D3 okay great night on D3 yes
octopus and uh takes takes takes a
bishop A1 so it was more or less Force
yeah right it takes
okay queen of two last move played
and both players with about 20 minutes
left
and that do we have time to quickly
check on Boris girlfriend's game
um
they have plenty of time well 24 I think
I'm hearing that that might be a good
one to check up on
kin on E6 wow look at that King look at
that King how did it happen
okay I'll quickly go through the
openings so we have Catalan
we have end game uh remember the the kid
ended up being on E6
so it looks a bit Pleasant a bit more
pleasant for white
another octopus Knight on D6 that's
right
so if all the king sets off are the king
is going the king is going
the king is going
nice simply so if y takes Rook F6 and we
get the Knight back
but Rook the seventh place so the king
potentially comes to D7
how did you like this route I liked I
like the king much yeah sure
if white tried one pair of Rook then
there will be no danger for the king
true and we may definitely say that
white has an advantage
and quite good chances to win the game
okay
Boris girlfriend here with whites
playing against hike
martirocian from Armenia
and this crazy game he played a couple
of days
that's right against her game of session
hmm
so viewers if you wish to check that
game just I think you will enjoy it yeah
okay
um now we have a move Anna in Fabiano's
game against Alexander predka and he
played indeed
Knight B6
after Rook C1 I think
Jesse
and there's another result there we can
see in uh David Anton's game is over
how did they play
I it's this well supposed to get some
Serbian so it should be a try I suppose
it was a draw
so these players also move to seven out
of 11.
right yeah there will be a big toy good
results of course good tournaments for
both of them
both of those players David Anton from
Spain and
America's Sam Seville
yeah but considering how many players
are on six
out of 10 and some of them will of
course win and they will catch up the
players who made the draw with six and a
half
I mean the tiebrex
for the Grand Prix spots well we'll have
to say we don't know yet how that's our
brakes we'll um
we'll work out
so um
let's see Alexander he played Knight B6
and after Rook C1
and what did we say here
for white
we said Bishop C6
Rook B8 perhaps
or even Rook d8 now because it works not
on the default
is Fabiano trying to win this do you
think
I don't think he's trying to win this
Bishop D4 I think we mentioned
I forget what we said after Bishop D4
uh we spoke about we should be five uh
Rook c797 this line
right it takes ticks 97
and we think black is
not in danger
E5 Pawn attacked
and black keeps this nice Pawn on A5
looks like Fab is about to play a move
but actually I missed one thing that's a
five it looks like Anna or like rugby
seven
I meant that after Rook B8 if white
takes takes I thought that was
impossible but actually like this line
in the end we have E6
still unclear because uh the a pawn is
dangerous it's dangerous absolutely yeah
ah we can take
okay then then it doesn't make sense it
doesn't work right
I think Fabi played Knight F5 didn't he
she play Knight F5 here
it's uh it's complicated that's for sure
so after Bishop B5 he's going to play E6
and second G7
sure
why not E6
maybe F takes E6
and then rookie seven
that's um
yeah it's becoming very sharp isn't it
so many pieces on the board so it's a
it's not that sharp as for example
mvl games
probably gets off from the ball there
after his last move Knight F5
maybe he wants to take on C7 first
and then preparing E6 right
on 96 as well could be coming next
for example Bishop D3
maybe even sacrifice on on G7 then with
E6 check
what about Knight C4 here on a knight C4
for black
and then what and E6
E6 anyway
I'm not sure it's sex or okay sex
E6 here perhaps yeah
every Bishop G7
right just maybe check at night
D6
or 96. you should be okay for black
yeah
[Music]
so there's a problem with this rock
and all these pieces
Knight C4
um not sure okay so Knight F5 has been
played
and um
and Bishop B5 we are waiting to see what
was Corona's idea
is this the composition
um this one before
he hasn't taken yet right
F5
still 9 moves
what about if black played Bishop B6
more solidly
I guess 94 94 right
okay
all right
it's not C4 possible
what happens what is your idea well just
to take on B2 yeah but if I take one E6
and then on sisa you take on E5 then B6
well let's see I can't see yeah let's
see four
and Knight takes Pawn Yeah
okay now it's good for weight sure
okay yep doesn't work
hmm
maybe we should do three
again Knight D4
and okay same idea here Knight C4 now
right so rather than Bishop B6 Bishop D3
yeah
attacking the night
and what about this sacrifice
ticks you have Rook is seven so maybe
it's not that dangerous yeah there will
be always check
even F6 rotation
[Music]
no this shouldn't work
so there is Bishop D3 there is Bishop B5
yeah maybe maybe Knight comes to E3
after Bishop D3
to prevent Knight C4
we can take now
also think about
um
well we'll have to come back to this
Anna and the others welcome back we will
of course also um let's also have a look
when we come back at you young against
Maxim
and David house game and so on so um
lots of dramas still to come here we'll
see you all in just a couple of
[Music]
foreign
this is the speed chess championship
finals going down here with Carlson and
Nakamura
the bullet portion comes to an end in
karnakamura is mathematically eliminated
in his chances and the bottom line is
Magnus Carlson shows why he is the
Magnus Carlsen
it has been hikaru's speeches
championship this 2018 and Wesley so had
an amazing event this year as well and
we were tied heading into bullet before
a car Nakamura separated himself in the
final portion
the blunders is rook and it's just
things are just not going well for
Wesley they traded back and forth
Landing heavy blows but ultimately the
heavyweight matchup is going to go
toward akaranakamura's favor
will be winning his third in a row
extremely impressive display once he
actually faced a deficit he has looked
like the best a car we've seen
foreign
[Music]
yes and welcome back everyone to all the
action here live from Riga Latvia and
it's round 11 of the feedhs.com grand
Swiss and women's Grand Swiss and we've
seen the top board in the open section
was drawn Anna so that gives alireza a
guaranteed spot in the candidates that's
the big story so far
and but plenty still to uh to look at
and we don't know who the second
candidates place will go to yet
this is the game um
we see uh well on the screen the photo
we see um
yep
against Maxim vashilagov very exciting
moments in that game and also um
Fabiano against Alexander predka is also
heating up let's say
so let's look at Maxim's game here we
are it's white smooth
and we were just looking at a
possibility and of Rook D1 to E1 with
some very sharp
continuations I think
so this looks like a logic
logic
there is nice is free
bit xs3 Rook B8
if K92 then of course it's a Checkmate
Queen F4 so Keen A1 is uh only move only
move after Queen A4 there is uh Queen A2
but there is another area with the Rook
takes E2 and if Rook takes you take the
bishop but if Bishop takes then there is
Queen Queen G3 attacking the rook and
also
stretching as well
quintos history so Queen D2 is Queen D2
is it possible also
uh one of the only most perhaps and and
now maybe Queen to C7
to stop Bishop C4 stop Bishop C4 and
threatening Queen to A5
it's still very complicated
and could white plays C4 or not I'm not
sure
uh then going to E5 oh Queen E5 check
wins correct Queen A5 and queen C3 this
is nice actually just play through let's
have a look Queen check
and that falls exactly yeah
oh and you Yankees play the move it was
not it was not Rook D2 E1 but he has
moved his skin sour
kin A1
okay King A1 getting out of the way of
all these nasty night checks
and sacrifices King A1
maybe he's preparing now
he may have seen exactly the line that
we just showed
so does black have time for eight six
or now after 86 there is
I can check this year on
is now possible
yes
three
takes takes
is it possible nice C3 bx3 okay turkey
eight Queen A4 Queen A2 let's have a
look that's what would happen
maybe let's first thing also moves like
E5
well rookie five yes
try to get a recovery to A5 but check
extremely sharp position
so this is H6 forum
Maxim just to have a square for his King
after watch King A1
and then
Bishop G2
okay Roxy Five there is rookie four
so Roxy 5 seems not to work
Rook E5 is still possible
okay
hmm
Goodness Me
super Sharp
H6 Bishop G2
no what about rookie I like rookie five
all right
sure so for this reason it's better to
have the Rook only one because then you
can take only for now you can take as
The Rook on the one is hanging
so maybe right so maybe not Bishop G2
you put G6 and he may play G6 not H6
looks like he's playing G6
but uh very similar idea of course
another no longer back rank mates
gives his King an escape Square g seven
to G6 and what is going to play after
rookie one
yeah that's the question
Rook te1
welcome back to you
Rook cd8 is that possible yeah I'm
thinking about that but then if the
queen most of C6 or B7
if Queen B7 may be Rook D4 yeah let's
check it
if
coincidence that's right here
wait turkey six uh rookie four
oh I see okay
foreign
where could widescreen go here let's
think
C4 yeah Queen C4 right
Queen C4 the Knight pinned in two
directions
here
Rook d e one
just wants to exchange pieces yes the
Knight has to go back to F6 so I can
trade
and um even Bishop takes A6 at the end
might be possible
looks like Rook D1 I know yeah
no a key moment for Maxime here what
does he have up his sleeve
both sides down to about 10 minutes
between 9 and 10 minutes each
and that was move 31 and it was it yeah
31 Queen G3 looks strange yeah I had the
idea to take only one after okay four
but uh
what
isn't obligation for
Queen G3 okay
then Bishop G2 maybe yeah I don't like
what else can Maxim do here
not clear at all huh
Rook cd8 we looked at quickly did Queen
C4 one C4 we felt
yeah and uh a Roxy Five what do we
a big moment here in this game what did
we say about drug Safari didn't consider
it in this position
if I have here
yeah
but it didn't work he's about to play a
move Maxim
um
indeed Rook C5 exactly right Anna model
Rook C5
razor sharp this game
Queen is now attacked
and um I think we have to take on sifa
and play the same game yeah
because what else
otherwise what work A5 check is
coming okay
maybe just Rook to E5
it looks good for for black
and if white takes takes or eight King
G7
well this would be interesting wouldn't
it
doesn't look bad for black
no with the Knight
it actually looks good
would you rather be black or white
though
I think black hmm
you'd rather take black here
he's taking his look and it may in fact
have been the only move
so they're going to reach this position
so now maybe some ideas with B3 and
Bishop C4
right can you do that
I'm a bit afraid to weaken the dark
squares but if white is on time to
to play Bishop before and then create
some threads
on the F7 Pawn then maybe it's okay
there's also the ILX a5a4
maybe we should move this Pawn Yeah
35 a form uh besides 8xb3 there's idea
like a queen yeah
let's try at least Bishop C4 A4
okay
and
um is Rook F1 dangerous
check
King A2
that we see young here okay Rook F7 is
not a Checkmate so we have time yeah
let's say we take
it could be a job Perpetual Checker if
nothing else so
but a very exciting draw
absolutely yeah
and still
a very unclear position
King G7 the last move and um
maybe King B1 here and I just get the
king
top the king back on B1
could be played
now how is some
Fabiana doing
um what's how did they get there what
happens to E3 Knight E3 Bishop B5 he
took on C7 and Eric is seven Yeah the
more I considered quite a safe mode work
day seven okay seven from black okay
Roxy one Rook D7 and Bishop E4 by
Fabiano Bishop D2 hmm
okay Rook attacked
could black try to there's some time
trouble here for Blackness he has less
than five minutes Alexander
so maybe he just wants to simplify
is your game yeah I'm less to think
about
or maybe a four as possible but a bishop
D2 played
so The Rook should move to
I guess B1 or A1 C5 perhaps C5
which move number is the center
35 35
so still five moves to go to the first
time control
yeah let's Chuck Rook so far
Rook C5 attacks the bishop of course
that's the time control at move 40 they
each get 50 minutes
for the next 20 moves and it moves 60 50
minutes
with 30 seconds increment per move plate
maybe bishop destreino
right
yeah I think that's the move Bishop D3
yep
Alexander tries to play in a safe manner
I mean just to trade some pieces right
yeah past the time control and then see
what happens
well the awful exchange of Works in
there which Fabiana declined
of course the Knight on B6 prevents Rook
C8 very important
and um
this is not the current position in the
game the current position in this one so
Fabiana still thinking where to play
where to put the Rook why to play here
right okay
wait to play well Rook C5 uh
looks natural to me
yeah Roxy Five then yeah
consider Bishop D3 frog D1
I think black takes only three right and
then trades
so um if Fabiano fails to win if this
game is a draw then
he's not guaranteed a candidate's place
Patrick C5
although I have to say Maxim's position
against you young years
maybe um
a bit more like a draw than it was
some time ago oh let's check let's check
or first let's check what was what is on
the play of The Rook so Rook C5 was
played yeah rocks if I was played and
also Alexander replied a bishop D3 okay
okay
by the way there was a result Anna in
the top Board of the women's section
and um
was it a draw
yeah I think they're true
we don't have the result yet but it's
just it seems to have ended to draw no
pieces to play with
okay so I think it's a good result
letting share who yeah who was in
troubles after the opening
but managed to solve her problems by
sacrificing to pause and then
go into the end game
okay back to Fabiano I think and um and
also Bishop Bishop D3 and which move did
Fabiano Play Bishop F3 no I think in
general the strategy to keep as many
pieces on the board as possible is the
right strategy not only that uh it's
like if you have more pieces then the
position is more complicated but uh also
with this Pawn white shouldn't trade the
pieces because then the pawn just is
just moving and when the pieces are on
the board there are some ideas with some
to create some complications
I was thinking of Knight A4 but then I
suppose uh Rooks here check followed by
Bishop A1
and the Knight would be misplaced
yeah somehow after 94 black loses the
coordination yes
so maybe yeah I agree yeah
the lights are misplaced
okay uh also Bishop C6
question about this right yes I didn't
see that
okay so not Knight F4
still uh it's complex isn't it
Alexander down to about three minutes
and he still has to make a few moves
foremost foremost to go until the time
control
top results there Anna in the women's
section so far
and then
the important director for Elizabeth
pets on board stream and here are the
results in the open section
uh many draws that's right
but still
uh Fabiano Corona is still playing and
you and he is still playing exactly two
key games there
and David Hallows is still going now
it's Alexander
is a threat
yes 94's a threat
and um what if Bishop G4
okay
looks um
where should the Rook remove just Rook
d8
perhaps
another year is to take on S3 than Rook
D5
followed by Knight C4
if they look more summer also Knight F4
could be played good or not
all right now
not sure
three results possible I think in this
game
somebody might blunder something
now the advantage could
go to either player
seems to be uh
finely balanced really Bishop takes E3
okay
and then maybe uh Rook C7 or not
um yeah it looks so nice C4
let's see what Fabiano has played he's
played quite fast
to say Alexander has
not much time left
and what's happened there now
which means we played Roxy six
okay
quite a few moves have come uh Bishop
Israel
F text C3 of course
and Knight C4
so if Bishop D4
okay
happy to play
these played Bishop D4
and he gets up from the ball though
it's his 40th move that's his 40th move
all right
he's probably going to have a look at
the Maxim's game against Yankee
and they added game they've entered the
game Anna what happened over there let's
have a look
it looks like it was a draw now from the
way the
softer King G7 looking at the game
there's there was only one move King B1
a queen D4 and Maxima for the draw
Maximo for the draw Maxima for dried it
was accepted so they got to move 30.
they actually got to move for 34. 34
right
well very interesting
and um that is the final position we
think on your screen
exciting game wasn't it and uh you well
we weren't sure that you had to evaluate
that final position
which
um which side would you rather be black
or white
but they have drawn the game and
there we see Alexander predker to make
his 40th move
so if Fabiano draws this one
I think his chances has excellent
chances too right
and it looks like he could
he shouldn't be in danger really
rookie seven from
black we think
okay seven right
and okay good good day past the first
time control yep now that that
additional 15 minutes without any big
accidents it looks like
and well Fabiano will know now that um
he's that much closer to getting the
second candidate spot
um as you young he did not win
that game was drawn
so is it drawing now enough for Fabiano
or not uh very likely we still have to
check uh David Howell's game right
because uh David or Vincent Kamer these
are the only two players who can catch
Fabiano if Fabiano makes a draw right so
we will definitely do that after a short
break very short break we'll see you all
just in a couple of
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to our Live program and we
are joined by Yu Yang Yi who just drew
his game with Maxim Bashir lagrav in the
final round of the grand Swiss
it seemed it was a tense game it was an
important game for both of you it could
determine the outcome of your placement
in the candidates for the candidates
could you take us what was going through
your head sort of during the game yeah
today and today is I play magazine yeah
it's a very interesting game yeah right
but I think maybe I'll uh I have a
missed chance here
because I miss uh 25 Korean before
because I think Rudy you are a nice B
text Rupiah
King everyone to Bishop it to King G3
and Miss Kong into Queen C7 yeah
yes maybe maybe
95 before before 95
I don't know yeah so when you when you
kind of realized that you missed these
moves during the game and bearing in
mind the all the entire context that
obviously a victory would have given you
clear chances for for uh for the tickets
to the candidates how did you come to
terms with that how did you come to
terms then with with the draw
yeah so today and today of course I just
want to show to win because yesterday I
missed a lot many many times yes
okay so so today the important thing was
not to miss even more than yesterday
okay yes uh
the other games are still going on
obviously the game between Carolina and
pradke a lot can determine that at this
stage what do you reckon your chances
would be and did you pay attention to
the game Karan and pretke
today I just played my game because I
think Carolina is better yeah you think
Iran is better yeah of course okay let's
just look back at your tournament at the
11 games
um what was the highlight for of the
tournament for you which was the best
game the most important game for you in
this tournament in this tournament which
was the best game for you the game you
enjoyed most
maybe playing Naya yeah with my airplane
yeah why
um
I think I play very
normal yeah yes because I think maybe
yesterday is better but a lot of chance
yeah I missed yeah okay obviously a lot
of emotions a lot of things to to
consider and things to think in overall
when you look at this tournament would
you say that it was a success for you
are you happy
um
I don't know yeah okay maybe you could
say but uh
I don't know
all right well Grandma thank you so much
and uh good luck okay thank you
Milan thank you very much and thanks
also to You Yankee there for giving us
that interview that
discussing his game and I think the
sharp line that we considered as well
yeah I think you mentioned we will just
quickly show you uh the critical moment
uh where I believe
uh ungi said that here he
intended to go for a rook D1 when he was
calculating the line a few months ago
but then he realized that yeah there was
this nice history and the line which we
shown here earlier checking a one and
important uh Rook takes E2 after Bishop
he took Windows three yeah that's
important and that's what you and he
mentioned after Queen deodores Queens of
seven and some
and after he
after he missed this one then he said
that he actually didn't see chances for
for him and he considered that the last
position was more or less equal more
less equal right okay
um well an exciting game for us here
um to watch and draw looks like a fair
result
so Fabiano there on camera
still playing against Alexander predker
and let's catch up with the position
Anna
he played Rook C5 A4 and one more move
I didn't see which one but if Fabiano
makes a draw here it's very likely that
he will qualify to the candidates too
Bishop C6 is played
unless I mean the tie breaks some very
strange results happen let's say and
either operands tybreak suddenly
improves a lot
and fabi's goes down or possibly um the
other game isn't it between David Howell
and Vincent Cameron we should check that
game as well Anna
um in a second see how they're doing
yeah yeah let's see if there are any
updates
so we saw when the players entered this
end game with uh Queen where Queen and
Paul were sister Rooks and I said that I
would expect a draw in this game
actually I still expect a drawing this
game right
they've got the time control
not yet okay now yes now they have and
look at that David played with two
seconds really two seconds on his clock
he made his move yeah he made the
smallest two seconds oh
well that was his 40th move so um time
management okay now he'll get 50 minutes
right Queen C3
and um
well like you I think this game will end
a draw it's um
it's hard to mention that white can eek
out a win here
um
a much less black as well
that's Vincent's camera
to make his 40 small he has
one minute and a half
but lots of draws today on it despite
very exciting games
um
yeah it started with so many sharp lines
so basically the players were ready to
fight but then it happened that
and I think this game may be heading
towards a draw very soon Anna should we
just keep an eye on this this is Fabi
against Alexander so A3 Bishop b59 B2
Bishop takes Bishop takes B5 Bishop A3
uh yeah very very likely
just not Bishop D7 because
he'll play what would be seven maybe
seven
it looks safe
and then E6 displayed
it looks like they get and there they
are handshake and that's a draw well
we think that really ought to be good
enough for Fabiana to get the second
candidate spot but nothing is certain is
it
um
because the tie breaks will obviously
depend on all the results in today's
round
but it looks like
should be good for Fabi to get that
second place yes before this round
Fabiana styberg was really much better
than uh Gregorio parents Ty break and
also better than David's house and
Vincent Gamers right
so we don't actually expect big
surprises but with this draw we can
actually say that alireza firoza he
became the winner of the tournament
that's right congratulations to him very
much so yeah that's eight points
8 out of 11 alireza
outright leader so big congratulations
to him
and uh in at Cypress second place we
have Fabiano
we have our Partin
and possibly one possibly either David
Hill or Vincent Kamer possibly but
unlikely but we don't that's right yeah
and um there we are winner
18 years old alireza Felucia
from Iran but representing France living
in France now for some years
and what a fantastic result for him and
up toward number four Anna as well
so here you can see the prices in the
open section the price fund being 475
000 US dollars with the first price 70
000 70 000 foreign it goes all the way
down to 40s place that's right where the
last prizes are two thousand dollars uh
not bad not bad at all
um there we see uh the players quite
amicably discussing the game Alexander
well good results please play the great
event he's finished high up he'll win a
good prize
and um he'll be satisfied while very
satisfied with his tournament
yeah and he is one of those who may get
the Grand Prix spot that's right also
we'll have to wait also that's important
as well to remind
everyone that there are six grand prix
spots here
um to be awarded
and that would come down to time breaks
pointed as well
so maybe we'll have an interview with
Fabiano
um
following his game
uh we'll see if we can manage that
meanwhile David Howell has whites here
against the Vincent Kamer that's the
current position
um pretty dry position dryer yeah
well
level I think we could see
white has Queen and pawn for the two
Rooks but um
just about impossible really for either
side to achieve much here
so um and also with the draw of course
they also um
both will win good prizes
and finish on
seven points
so
not a position where you want to take
huge risks to try to win with either
side
so maybe we can check how Corey is doing
in the women's section
okay
uh this game ended in a draw also my
sister made a draw against harika
Elise won against Bibi Sarah and yes
that's right made her last Norm so she
will officially become a grand master of
this event
and uh many GM Norms I think we had four
GM Norms achieved in the women's section
didn't we so we have a religious Village
and Elizabeth today getting the title
this is Olga badelka who has white
against Daisy Curry
and she's close to
this game
definitely good for whites
material advantage
yep and um
well
maybe not an easy win
a good tournament for Daisy Corey
who started with three losses three
defeats but then he did but then one
five in a row but then one five in a row
amazing and after a draw she won another
game correct so she's on plus three
having a great event but maybe she will
she will lose this game
yeah she still has some chances I agree
but
objectively speaking it should be
waiting for white right
okay
which other games by the way Jesse
February Anna do we do we have a quick
look because I think she
very tough time she's still playing
there she is and is she going to um get
something from this game
she's doing well
not she's pulling up
and at the very least she can she can
actually have a Perpetual check that's
right
so she's about to make some more I think
Queen D7
or queen F6
let's see what she did
uh can't you play for a while
if she takes on A4 then Queen CS3
and then um King somewhere
King B6 or something
but I don't believe she will lose this
one no so the first game where she will
score something well that's great isn't
it for her as well yeah I mean it will
be a pleasant end of the tournament
because after losing all the games so
then actually you're happy to get off
the mark on the last day and uh well she
may be able to even get get a win here
but certainly a draw is there
if she wants it immediately or um kind
of a worst case scenario where the game
would be a draw
so um
very well done to her and that game is
still in progress as are many other
games
but basically in the open uh section
well probably just the Vincent camera
against David Hull is the only top game
still
remaining
and in the women's section Alexandra
costanuk is still playing
so these players are on 6 out of ten
and how is she doing not so clear Milan
we now have an interview so over to you
thank you very much yes we're joined by
Fabiano Carolina how satisfied are you
with this outcome
well I I think it probably secures
qualification
um I'm not 100 sure but I I think nobody
is we're still debating on that but oh
I I guess the best thing to say is it's
very likely that it secures your quality
yeah I thought the most dangerous game
was uh Maxime against uang Yi
um and I I was very worried for both of
them at some point I was hoping for a
draw but uh maximum's position looked
extremely suspicious and that and near
the end I already thought he was uh
umi's position was very dangerous what
once the night was only four Queen on F4
um but okay my own game I didn't I feel
I had so many chances
um probably I was even slightly worse at
some point uh because he was super well
prepared this whole line
um
yeah I kind of knew it was possible but
I didn't know the details and um after
94 I just didn't really know what to do
it's it's super sharp uh I thought
Bishop B2 is interesting
but then this queen before Queen D2
looked like a nice maneuver and after
that I'm certainly not any better I was
kind of
worried that I might come under pressure
uh because he has a past Apon which is
very dangerous
but I never felt like I was in real
danger so how difficult was it to play
your game and at the same time watching
the game with you and MBL because
obviously it wasn't everything in your
hands a lot depends on what happened in
that game and still a lot depends on
others so how how is it to play in such
circumstances well I thought before the
game it's sort of entirely in my hands I
mean if I win I'm I guess I'm just
guaranteed um yeah
so I was a bit disappointed that I
didn't really make much of the game and
I kind of relied on others to to not
surpass me
um
but okay it's also you know it's not
easy to win games in this tournament
everyone is very strong
um and today I also played an extremely
strong player I didn't think it would be
an easy game I was just hoping to put
more pressure on him so what are the
highlights for you from these 11 games
and 11 days in Riga what were the key
moments and the most important takeaways
from this
um
well I only really had had one moment
that I kind of felt very happy about
when I beat farrugia I was extremely
happy about this game the rest was kind
of uh it was a tough tournament it was
really tough
um both the length of the tournament and
the length of the games I I kind of felt
exhausted
um
after after I beat fruja I just had no
energy left
um
so I was also happy that I could get
that I could draw Maxime
um because like my energy level is
pretty much at zero now
so how did you manage to get your energy
back did you did you go out for walks
did you sleep longer what did you do
yeah
um
well we I mean the only thing really to
do is to go for walks uh that's the only
thing available to us so yeah we
couldn't go anywhere else yeah so so we
were walking quite a lot and the park
it's a beautiful city and there's a lot
of nice parks and places to walk
um so that was a good way to kind of
relieve some tension
um
and watched some movies you know things
like that uh
um but yeah it's it's been a tough
tournament so overall would you say you
enjoyed Riga or the answer to that
question depends on the outcome of the
of the final games here yeah well
assuming that uh that I qualified that
was what I came here for
um
you know I I didn't win the tournament
normally that's the goal to win the
tournament but here it's sort of a
different goal and if that happens then
I'm happy because I got what I came for
okay what's next for you where to from
here
um well I'll go back home and then I'll
do commentary for the world championship
match for chess.com and uh
and that's it for for playing for for
now the rest of the year I I well
there's a blitz tournament tomorrow
which I'll play uh I just I took this
decision so you will be playing tomorrow
in the blitz yeah now I kind of feel
like uh I don't really want to play but
okay I took this decision a while ago
and uh and yeah in terms of Chess
playing
um there's not much else for the rest of
the year for us all right yeah well
thank you very much it's been great
having you here and interviewing you so
thank you so much and uh hope it all
works out thank you
yes Milan thank you very much and
Fabiano there he said he came here to
get one of those two
candidates places and he's barring some
very very bizarre uh results in in for
Ty breaks and he's achieved that Anna so
mission accomplished yeah I think to be
honest uh quite happy about that and of
course every player especially every top
player come in here I think they were
mainly concentrated and trying to get
one of these kind of spots and well done
to alireza firoza and we're likely to
Fabiana Corona right who made it yeah an
exciting game as well the fabi's game
today
and as he said that he was keeping an
eye on
mbos game with you Yankee
but that also finished to draw of course
in fact all the top games Anna have
finished in draws
and
nine of the top ten this is the only
other game still going from those top
ten
and it's David Hall who else
playing um against Vincent
actual Board number nine and Board
number 10 is still in progress but we
didn't cover the these games so closely
because uh on boards 9 and 10 the
players are the players have six six
points right okay out of ten so they
were not in the competition
for the candidate sports but candidate
sports but they are still in the
competition for for the grand priest for
the Grand Prix spots yeah and also for a
very good price as well
so do we think um either side has
chances here in this game Anna um
David against Vincent
uh Let me refresh this
Anya
Imus no it seems like rookie forward the
last move and David David was so so
happy to get to digital 50 minutes now
he can think
he had two seconds when he played his
last move yeah it looked like he made
his last move was two seconds on the
clock
well okay um there they are and um
that's the position
yeah yesterday David suffer
Ed by alireza firoza
fought well and found some nice tricks
but then in the time travel he couldn't
calculate precisely all the lines and he
lost his track and later on that game it
was already difficult to save this game
uh but today he came up for a new game
and he was trying and actually this is
the current position
um but but we believe it's quite
difficult to I mean black has the
weaknesses
and um white has to keep defending the
before Pawn
both kings are safe
it's hard to imagine uh something
happening here that would give either
player a serious
serious winning chances
but uh you know
seems like David wants to keep playing
this one out
he will he's used for long games yeah
like our his game is
it's a real alarm lasting for for at
least five six hours
I know David is looking forward to the
bits tomorrow as well he told us that
he's definitely going to pay the Blitz
and um
yes don't forget tomorrow is a blitz
tournament right so this tournament will
be our today but tomorrow I have a blitz
event right with 18 rounds nine double
around nine double rounds so many games
and here
we are waiting for them men and women
all playing together in the same uh
tournament
and no separate tournament men and women
play in one tournament but there are
prizes there are
like ten thousand uh dollars overall
first prize
and there are women's prizes as well
yeah the first one being three thousand
I believe okay
and we just heard Fabiana say that he
will be playing as well in the Blitz
um
so we look forward to that and it's also
in honor Anna of Mikhail Tel that
someone who would I think the following
day would have been 85 years old
uh not tomorrow but the day after
tomorrow would be his or it's his 85th
birthday
so um extra special as well to be able
to be here in Latvia and have the blitz
tomorrow
remembering um
what a great play he was Michael tal and
his legacy
uh to chess and chess players
so here's um David Howe trying to
squeeze something out of nothing
we could say that
water out of the stone which I
understand
maybe you have some questions from the
chat where would we actually let to
answer some of them
something
I'm sure if David would offer a draw
with his next move then black would
accept didn't you let's say why it
played King F3 or something and offered
to draw
um
or do you think black is playing for a
win here
I didn't know who's playing for
I feel like both players may be happy
with the draw so I wouldn't be surprised
if this game ends soon
would you well I
I'm sure it'll be a draw yeah
um show us one can be but uh let's see
I think black is preparing some H5
then like an oracle 6 G6 and just stay
it's hard to think of any plan
um here for um
for either side
so uh well
it really does look like fabi's got that
second candidates place I think for for
him not you know for the topics to
against to go against him would be uh
very very
bizarre indeed
um
possibly mathematically it's still
feasible that all the results go against
him and they all go in favor of or
pardon for example
but there were like Five Points
yeah it's uh one two can still be a
but we think that Fabiano has
has got that place
and uh yeah well that's what he came
here for as we said already so um
and I suppose Anna looking back at the
tournaments although there's still some
games in progress
alireza and Fabiano deserving of those
two places yeah they played really well
and
Fabiano mentioned that his win or
alireza was The crucial absolutely key
that's right well the only defeated
alirez has suffered
and um
and Maxine was one of those players
who've been up there the whole time but
just just a half of one shot
that's right
um yeah
so maybe now we can check some other
games as more or less everything that is
decided of course we can't say it right
at this point but well very likely with
like 95 percent at least everything is
decided
uh so
what about Board number nines non-60
against Nikita with your golf okay two
Russian players right
who lost your pardon yesterday of course
which
put an end to his chances of uh of
qualifying
how is he doing today too
Ken white player Rook H7 uh and if King
is six uh maybe a rook C7
right
what's his sacrifice his Queen to get to
this position
yeah it's Queen for Rook Bishop
and also black has a prawn
yeah
Rook checking Rook C7
well it was the first thing I saw maybe
there are some other options
Black's last move was King F7
but this looks quite logical
let's have a look then check so okay
check
King will come to E6 Rook C7
if the bishop retreats to A8
foreign
very suspicious yeah
Rook H7 the other Rook to H7 or not
or is there something better
or D1
yeah
what do you want you like
you didn't aggregate seven before we
could uh Records 127
no I actually liked it
doubling Brooks on the seventh rank yeah
then their daddy I was Rook D7 uh also
Rook F7 right
yeah okay seven that's right yeah Flex
King sort of stuck almost animating that
though
looks quite dangerous for black
the King on E6 it looks very dangerous
indeed so maybe black should try to find
chances in activity if King goes back
then what do we do we can still play
roxy7 and okay going back it looks
strange considering
right here so uh Kinder six were likely
Eric to C7 maybe King D6
that's a better move I agree King D6
definitely better yeah
yeah I missed that
um F7
if it detects E4 I wanted to play Rook
D1
okay
and if farook is six maybe Still Rock
the one
oh okay shades
I don't know lots of excitement here we
think might sing very well
but actually I can't take on D5 because
takes takes Rook takes Queen takes right
now
so then Rook D1 is not that dangerous
but Rook eight eight threatening
checkmates or
more or less five texts
well
I think it's good for whites
um
okay uh maybe Anna we have a very quick
break and um we think that Fabiano has
got the second candidates place
um we're more or less certain of that
but uh maybe we'll just confirm that
um all the artist will confirm that very
very soon so we'll be back anyway in a
couple of minutes uh and we'll be
following the current games and giving
you updates with the results the new
chess.com events page has arrived
find all the games from Top tournaments
around the world as well as
championships played right here on
chess.com
support each game and even vote on who
you think will win their matchups review
standings schedules key information and
find links to all the top news
surrounding each event
head to chess.com events today and
experience your favorite tournaments
like never before
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
aeon has an aggressive intuitive style
he has a good feeling for chess
especially when he plays with the
initiative and he likes to put pressure
on his opponents he's just overall
confident and full of ideas he can play
extremely well in it and if he comes to
the match at his very best then maybe he
can play better than Magnus
oh no
and welcome back uh Anna music and
myself sure Conquest here we are live
from Riga Latvia and it's day 11 the
last round of the feed a chess.com
groundswiss and women's Grand Swiss and
Anna this is David house game against
Vincent Kamar and David has just played
H4
updates about this game just one moment
H4 has been played I think H5 maybe the
reply from black side but really the
position stays the same and well this
game is Just
it's going to be ended soon let's hope
so let's hope we won't have 11 hours of
watching this end you don't see any
winning chances for either side no as
long as they just stay
stay put here
I mean if neither side takes a risk
imagine
uh how to
how to create some mess on the board
right I agree out of this position I
mean what what does either side have to
do in order to lose this
um
well but um
we don't know if
either side is offered a job it's uh
doesn't look like it
Vincent looking around a little bit
yeah looking where I draw it so maybe
let's check some games in the women's
section sure I think uh
it's more interesting oh that's Jesse by
the way look yeah let's take a look uh
Jesse's game so here we are
how is she doing
can she win
so this is the current position
Queen is 16 A7 now she's two points two
pawns up and really just a one end game
this for her
wouldn't that be lovely if she managed
to win uh after
losing nine games on the shot to win the
last one
try ten games
and then you have her for the interview
of course how do you feel about winning
the last game of course we get evidence
for you
uh well hey so she's playing I mean
looks her opponent is rated two three
seven seven Alina bivor
Jesse's rating just 1857.
so I'm sure that's
should be over the moon to win this game
maybe it's the highest rated opponent
she would manage to bid if she wins this
one
yeah I'm not sure um
who she played right now um the other
games but uh
is making a move now let's see what she
does I remember she made a draw against
Valentina the Women's World Cup in the
first round she lost the first game and
then she was actually quite close to win
the second game but in the second game
she went for the repetition
and uh
the tournament she said that she was
actually happy to take this draw because
it's the highest rated opponent she has
ever managed to hold the game with right
to get Valentina yeah
well here
um she has a one position no question
about that
King E7 could move
so if there is a check
uh we will play Queen D7 and then the
movie The King will come with a check
correct maybe you're actually quite
close to the Checkmate sure
um
well well done to her uh
if she wins this game
which other games Anna do we how should
we have a quick look at highlight of
today's day here we have Alexandra
costanoke against
foreign Knight C4 being the last move
played all right black is an exchange up
right at the moment but the bishop
Sanders attack the queen is under the
attack also the kid is quite weak yeah
Queen C5 check coming so maybe black
should actually take this Knight
um Bishop C4 and now there are different
options
[Music]
maybe then there are some checks hmm
okay
maybe so maybe it's a draw maybe Jewish
yeah
it could be all right that's Alexandra's
game
uh we also have Daenerys at vacasoa
against Pierre crumlin then we say
Alexandra on camera
after having played Knight C4 and check
on D1 Anna
check it's not it's not a checklist oh
it's not a checkup yes it's not a chick
looks risky just a second Queen D1
immediately within Queen C5
Queen C5 check
so maybe it can be eight
looks a bit scary suddenly would not be
six
we'll have to see
um what happens
um Anna I think um sorry I think Peter
Douglas is now ready to show us
something so Pete
thank you in a more quiet period of the
show and waiting for some final
mathematics to calculate Fabiano's
final entry in the candidates I believe
we are also looking at the other boards
the lower boards because there are some
nice games played and I wanted to show
you the Clash of today between
nilsgranddalius of Sweden against
Matthias bluebaum of of Germany which
started with a French Advance when we
say French Advance we say nimswitch who
has his birthday today if it would still
be alive and in this game
E2 were played and I think the actual
critical main lines are
with Queen B6 and and or with C4 but
this is just much more quiet and people
are just developing
black is preventing B4 here
what just improves his position with A4
and we start the game a bit later
so I'm just going to make this move to
show you how this all appeared this felt
a little bit risky to me this trade here
but
only here
black makes a mistake I think with F5
engines prefer even though it doesn't
look great either it is actually
technically much better to go G6 in this
position there is an issue with F5
and that is he takes Rook takes yeah
there you see it already it's very
sensitive touch screen so sometimes I'm
pressing two moves where I want to press
one
the issue is of course the long diagonal
according to Black it's not really a
problem because black just can go to to
F7 with the King but as we will see
white will get actually get an attack
himself instead of black
I like this move a lot Bishop E3 it's
just a developing move but also the idea
is if black ever takes we actually want
to take with the F Pawn and open up the
f file for ourselves Black Goes Knight
E5 Queen H7
King F7
now white swaps on A7
and
always check the threads of Black Knight
G4 might actually be a threat here
attacking both H2 and F2 and I always
like in the such situations when the
solution to the problem is to just
develop another piece which is well
there are more moves to provide but I
like Rook ae1 ignoring sort of the
thread of Knight G4
and now just H3
so he's letting go of F2
and again there is there's uh also a
rook E3 move very good for white but
Nils Cornelius idea of was Bishop G6
check and now things start to get really
interesting
if black swaps
then The Rook has to go back otherwise
you lose this Rook
but there's actually a problem here
you don't want to take with the queen
now because of the pin with Rook F1
yeah but then this is not great either
because on the next move you will lose
G7 with check so clearly not what black
wanted so a nice
Bishop G6
check here
that had to be ignored with King E7
Nils continues in style with Bishop F5
shutting the Rook from protecting the
Knight so the Knight is actually hanging
here using the pin over the E file
King D6 attacking the bishop again
and then with everything that's hanging
Niels just decides let me throw in my
last piece always use all your pieces on
the board he puts his Knight on a nice
Central Square and after night
takes takes
takes
the Whitehead awaiting attack and the
German Grandmaster blue bomb was very
supportive today and he actually allowed
a Checkmate on the board with a king
going all the way to E3
and queen F2 was checkmate
so that was one of the nicer games of of
this round so let's go back to Anna and
Stewart
thank you very much Pete said that was a
great game from Niels crandellias
yeah and um yeah Bishop G6 that was a
particularly
wonderful move and uh yeah great win
very nice to see that
so um
what did we say Anna about this game
Alexandra costaneuk against munguntu
from Mongolia
maybe we can expect a Perpetual check in
this game uh Queen if I was played
actually after first coinci 5 can be
eight Queen E5 King A7 now right okay so
if Queen C5 or queen A5 it just leads to
per petal check right okay
or don't take any side can can play for
a win here okay
all right good uh what about Nana
zagnitza
she's playing antoinetta she's playing
antonetta former world champion she's a
pond arm
but it's not clear
I think she has some drawing chances in
this position hero Queen is active
uh she can try to
to attack on B6
okay
yeah but she's fighting for a drone
clearly uh yeah black house black is the
one with winning chances to a point up
um a king G6 the last move
and Pia's game we started talking about
it and then we moved to another game Pia
is a pawn up in this Rook end game
and her chances to win I think they are
higher than Stefano's chances to win in
the Queen's end game okay
yeah she's uh she's doing okay though
pulling up and uh with the black pieces
yeah fairly good winning chances for
Pierre who hasn't had a fantastic
Adventure ship here that maybe she's
she's won a few games they are B4 from
Dinara
she started quite poorly I think Pierre
yeah but then in the last rounds she won
a couple of games and uh now she is on a
five and a half out of ten so plus one
all right
maybe actually after
a B4 how can we find chances to win and
can we do it at all yeah we see the um
the gaming question up here with her
back to us
because if we try this one then it's uh
quite drawish
and if A4 uh B5 will come if I have
install this pawns will be exchanged
that's right
do you have any idea like the rookie
five rookie 4 maybe not really
and then it would be to check Force the
white king back but still
there we are and the Arbiters
placed the new score sheet cell on the
table
you can try to attack on H2 like after
B1 and drook H1
but after King G3
likely to be draw isn't it
very precise move I think
we may also expect A4 has been played in
B5 okay
a couple of moves I see uh well not that
much has changed but David Halligan's
Vincent Kamer
that game is still going on
Roxy four Queen D2 and the King G6 so
black didn't go for H5 King H3 and this
is the current position okay the
structure is the same
right
Vincent has just made a move
I think
Rook E4
should white player F3 or not
doesn't really change anything does it I
have a question what for trying to play
for a win well I don't know
F3 just Strokes yes we're practicing for
black as outputs for his works
David taking his glasses off there maybe
they will after all agree a drawer in
the next move or two
we'll see
David's played a very good songs of
course
and uh draw today still keeps him in a
high position
and just that game yesterday really
against
alireza let's set him back
having won four games on the trot
hello
please see one four in a row the four
before he played uh alireza
Queen C3 looks like
yeah Queen's history played
sorry myself maybe some kind of
repetition now that's right
and boss of the players are already
quite exhausted
then we see grenka
clearly one of Vincent's sponsors
and a big chair sponsor in Germany
it looks like David is ready for a draw
I agree I agree yeah at this moment I
agree
and I don't believe a Blackwell play for
a win no
okay
so that will mean that all the top eight
boards at least are drawn
um that exciting game that Nikita
vitugov has
we could maybe return to
wear white
right
sex and The Rook D1 without Rook C7 Rook
D1
F5
F6 F5 wow yeah it's funny if white takes
then King moves and it's a check check
but do we expected troxy7 now
foreign
and then some idea was like
a rook F7 F5 it does look like they're
gonna have a troll isn't it Anna Vincent
is looking up
okay for instance plays Rook C4 then we
can okay he's playing Rook so far and
this may just be a repetition of moves
coming up
so if they make a draw that means that
uh uh these players and Vincent and
David they wouldn't be able to
to catch Fabiano I think he's offered a
draw in fact and she looked like Vincent
came and they offered a draw he said
something to David
and it's going to be accepted I believe
yeah I think so too
which would mean that Fabiano and
Gregorio Parlin share second third place
correct yeah but uh fabiana's tie break
was just much much better uh correct
well it's just impossible that a parent
can surprise Fabiana right
understandings right okay so um we can
more or less call this uh call that sir
that Fabiano's got the second place
second kind of last place
let's play the move
David Hall he's turned down a draw
he has played Queen to B2
priest
a long night ahead
Queen B2 this will never end no I mean
it's not like I wish to end it but when
the position is so dry and I don't
really see
any real chances unless some huge
blunder
I I have to agree I didn't see a
any plan for why it's here at all
but um
well
a bit of a surprise actually I really
thought that was going to be uh
a draw by repetition no no Stewart no no
no life is not that easy don't even
think about that
okay let's check women's KISS Sure for a
party what's Chelsea doing let's have a
look at Jesse's game is she going to win
her game against yeah repetition
Perpetual check uh Olga badelka how is
she doing
this game
Knight C4 D6 check
and the plug takes only six white ticks
on C5 yeah if black players can be so
exciting I believe Knight C4 is going to
happen
about just a second can can be six how
to win this one
yeah exactly how to win it oh okay if we
win the C5 Pawn then we put one Knight
on D3 and another one on A2 and we take
one before and that's how we win
so how do we win the season so just
Knight B7 you think
I might be seven yeah
yeah and C4 C4
yeah good resource
maybe after C4 we take
six King six A6 Chuck check
and is this an easy win
King A5
for example
okay should be
yeah it should be quite easy I play
Knight B3 then C5 then regroup the
Knight re-maneuver it to D4 but maybe
even I can make it without taking on C I
mean without allowancy for if
check can be five they're on camera
we're seeing um this is not the person
we're seeing on the camera we're seeing
their Jersey February from South Africa
who we think is going to win her first
game which is actually score here for
the first time
um
sadly she's lost all her games so far
but she has a completely winning
position uh Jesse is so close during
this tournament on a high note
so Queen is sex Queen uh Quincy 3 King
F7
threatening Queen G6 right if Queen G7
King 8
that's right
uh queen of seven
this has to watch out for some stalemate
tricks maybe like let's say after Queen
C3 she has to be careful not to take
that pawn because all the stable
stalemate right yes but she has Queen F6
check of course
this move so this is the only trick she
has to avoid something like that right
but um
she is a few moves away from uh from
Victory which uh well be great nice a
nice perfect finish for her
she's gonna go two minutes on the clock
correct and it's more number eight here
eighty she has worked so hard hmm
well she has uh she's got lots of fans
lots of people uh following her games
and I think she's been streaming during
the tournaments at least the first half
of the tournament every day right and
maybe she continued after in the second
half I don't know I didn't check
so big headline here big story for her
if she indeed goes on to win this but
she I mean and how
sorry uh
uh what did she say if it was ever a
loss all right I'm learning a lot she's
learning a lot from her losses
but um
very sweet finish for her if she wins
this game as she really ought to
to uh we'll just uh maybe get her for an
interview after her game that would be
nice wouldn't it
to hear from her she's been in the
studio here before so it'd be lovely to
uh
get her reaction
once this game is over
and we think she's a few moves away from
victory
so yeah starting with 10 losses
losing 10 games yeah and and now she's
so close to win this one that's right
I believe that now in the chat there are
many supportive messages I'm sure for
Jesse uh black black has moved like a
smooth what do we know what she's done
going to C7
okay
can we actually Force
uh the porn end game
after Queen takes F4 check after Queen
takes a four I was going to
I was going to play queen king to E8
right King G8 King GA the only move
Queen to E6
King G7 King G7 and then queen of six is
the swinging
no the king is uh kings in the Square
King is in the Square
she's played a move uh I think
um
so if Queen takes a four then Queen
seven wins
or couldn't be a check
if Queen B8 I think she wants to play
Kenny seven
right
sure and after Quincy 7 came to f8
as long as she doesn't repeat uh three
times
that wouldn't be good
um I don't know
can we see the board no we're keeping an
eye on David house came there but
no we meant another board
we can't suggest is uh the actual moves
in her game
okay yeah
for Queen F7 F 28 28.
yeah and now it's uh game over
if she gets this
Queenstown has been played all right so
king of f8 was saying
seems to do the trick King f8 here
can I fight maybe a black goes here can
eat
right
and that's small is it
come on Jesse
if only seen you that you are covering
her game right now
it's got inside two minutes
of course she does get 30 seconds of
move increment
and playing someone who's
500 rating points higher rated than her
something like that
King f8 we think is
but I think Jessica was close to 2 000
or maybe she even uh and then she
dropped maybe she was even higher
okay
I think she's the African women's
champion by the way
foreign maybe even more than once
Queen D7 has been played
or not yeah Queen the sound has been
played
oh did we have this possession before
we thought King f8 but now what would
happen if King if Queen takes f4c
Queen takes poem
Where is the where's the easy win is
there an easy win or not it was more
easy with skin effect
oh but you know she could play Queen H3
check
King G8 Queen E6 check
that's uh
does the trick
but uh
King G7
yeah I saw it and then I forgot
so queen of History check I think is one
way to
one of many one of many she just needs
one
one way to win is enough
hasn't been played oh not yet okay
but it's hard to think of another move
that black could play here
Queen takes F4
otherwise um
you can try to find five other ones
it feels nice isn't it yeah Queen h31 on
them yeah if King G7 and queen H6
okay come on the queen H3 check let's
finish it Queen Nutri check and then
Queen E6 check and forces exchange of
Queens
but she did something else I think
what did she play I think she moved to
King now
King E6 check Maybe
why did she do that
what's the so what happens King
King G8
is he an easy win
or not
so if check in G7
King G8 has been played
now it's less clear
yeah Queen H3 was instantly uh just
waiting on this winning on the spot
and she had time as well she had a
couple of minutes then
two minutes
check
okay we'll go to H7 it goes to H7 yeah
like must avoid an exchange of Queens
not as easy as it was I know yeah she
just gave this F4 Pawn for no reason
well
hmm
well let's let's hope that she's still
uh wins this game
what has she played
no I think it's actually closer to a
draw I mean objectively it's winning but
uh
after she blundered that pawn
yeah
she played something
appreciate
so she cannot force an exchange of
Queens with check now that's the that's
the point if you could have done before
with Queen H3
so
let's see
she has an extra Pawn but uh
but you had to yeah that was Queen she
was just a game that was just over
wasn't it it was just the end of the
game one move from uh from victory
and she didn't find it
and she has inside two minutes so every
move she gets 30 seconds but
not least is it I don't know not so
simple
by any means
okay buckerson Falls
okay if she bring the queen to
I mean the way to win is to gradually
push our airport up isn't it but um has
to bring the queen to the center somehow
yeah Queen C5 something like that
and then try to push the pawn
and try to push the airport but that's a
big technical operation now
um
I think it's a draft for Quincy
yeah lots of checks
talking to six uh queen of Fate against
the six Queen City
what has she played
King D7
so she just gave the pawn yeah and now
there's going to be lots of checks
and uh she may not now she can't escape
if she goes here
Queen E4
oh dear and now she just
I I wouldn't say it even a blunder she
just threw it away yeah
one move one move from victory
Queen history check and it was all over
and she had two minutes on the clock at
that time
well
big Miss yeah it's a real shame as well
because to to finish uh with the victory
today
uh would have been uh really really nice
for her
but instead we think it may just now
be a draw should we keep an eye on the
other game Santa we can always come back
to this
David Howell still playing there look so
who is still playing and Nana is still
playing how's David doing anything
happens but nana doesn't do great I
think now she's losing
David's game
you know Vincent returning to the board
right yeah but it was better to have the
Queen the King on H7 to be ready to play
G6 now there are some ideas to bring the
queen to G5 of course it can be blocked
by a rook F6
some pressure from White you think
so if I go here
Queen 8 k96 okay six sure
Queenie check King
he's played Rook F6
King H6
Maybe
half a chance for David or not
I suppose Rook takes B4 is a threat
isn't it
yeah now it is
so um
okay
what can
we expect from David here
Queen E7
let's see much hard to get to G5
I look E4
still seems like nothing much is um
happens changed
right yeah
black has everything defended every Pawn
is defended the Rooks are defended the
king is safe
I don't see how it can go wrong right
black and play music C4 and just uh
white king can never
get in
yeah really hard to see this game not
finishing in a draw soon as well
okay which other games Anna can we still
uh
keep track of
how did the
well this is a game lower downers that
we haven't seen at all
who is better and why
I think white is better yeah
but it's
yeah
so before we take
F5 for the last move
Eric D5
Maybe
takes a
actually this Rook is under attack
yeah
but okay still if I take on V6 why
trying to get the Rook into A8
and then if Bishop takes H3
what would happen
thanks okay seven okay second is seven
black would take
I suppose b6a7
Queen G7 uh King G7
David meanwhile has played quinnier
check
s
[Music]
so here what would happen
um
why to play on a bishop take on A7 or
let me just take it yeah I know that's
right then bring the bishop to E6
let's say I don't know Queen E5 is also
possible
foreign
against Rach manov
and still in progress
and if not a takes B6
maybe Rook H4
looks somewhere
okay it's four okay
oh I see it in the pawn is pins yeah and
also another one is following G5 is
falling as well
yeah that's the problem
that is definitely a problem for white
if Queen E5
um
if black tags you take then Bishop is
six right yeah
just give the Rook Bishop comes three
six afterwards
maybe a black should try E3
yeah could do
F take C3 Queen h8 Jack and David's game
but the guy came back King cheese right
okay
looks like it could now be a draw Anna
or not I I think it's too early
should we just go back there we can see
them
repeating moves at least once
move
so if queen hhx king G6 quinier check
will just be a draw
by repetition
if white wants to do anything else well
The Rook trip takes B4 is um is a threat
queen of sun doesn't strike anything
that's right yeah then just looking for
back it really feels like this is time
to um
just to keep checking and uh agree a
draw
any reason could he play F3 and E4 just
to give this Pawn up
make a postpone it looks very odd
so let's checkups right F3 okay takes E4
trying to win
or trying to lose
not sure
it takes ticks
half a chance maybe four wait
a fire Queen yeah
okay if I play Rook B3 what's happening
B3 uh preparing this or that if Queen E5
then Norwich is six
yeah you can do that yeah
Queen d8 Maybe
I don't think David will do this
so maybe check
and he can still accept the draw here
right
but if he wants to continue
I really don't think this is going to
happen but um and I believe that even
after Rook F3
finally he will have to take the draw
well David it looks like he's still
calculating
we see him there very focused on his
game we're going to take a very short
break Anna and then we will come back
and see uh the conclusion
we assume conclusion of that game
and um David Hall there uh to play
playing against Vincent Kamer from
Germany and a few other games still
going as well so we'll catch up with
those results and we'll see you all in
just a couple
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome welcome everyone this is the
speed chess championship finals going
down here with Carlson and Nakamura
the bullet portion comes to an end in
coronakamura is mathematically
eliminated in his chances and the bottom
line is Magnus Carlson shows why he is
the Magnus Carlsen
it has been hikaru's speed Chess
Championship this 2018 and Wesley so had
an amazing event this year as well and
we were tied heading into bullet before
akaranakamura separated himself in the
final portion
the blunders is rook and it's just
things are just not going well for
Wesley they traded back and forth
Landing heavy blows but ultimately the
heavyweight matchup is going to go
towards akaranakamura's favor
will be winning his third in a row
extremely impressive display once he
actually faced a deficit he has looked
like the best a car we've seen
[Music]
and welcome back everyone I am Anna
music here with Stuart conquest and we
believe we are actually approaching the
end of this tournament it's just one
game which is actually very interesting
for us in terms of uh who will get the
second uh spot for the candidates and
this is the game between David Howell
and Vincent Kamer we are actually
expecting a draw in this game but David
is trying to find some chances he
already refused a drone that's offered
by Evanston a few minutes ago but to be
honest we can't really find any real
chances in this game and it's also done
it looks like to about six minutes on it
to reach move 60.
so they've played what 52 moves I think
so still eight moves to go to
to the second time control
they have all rdmd players already
repeated dispositional once
and F3 was not played but it was
something suggested well from ourselves
to continue the battle after which
actually the relation Still Remains
equal
and I don't know why it really needs to
go there I really think it's time to um
Queen E7 is it
looks like Queen E7
after which perhaps rookie 4 will come
again
actually David's simply looking at his
score sheet they're almost to check that
he wasn't about to repeat three times
perhaps
um
we had
this position okay this is one of the
positions where the queen on E7
otherwise we didn't have the position
with the queen only seven
and Vincent has played his move ready
rookie four no surprises and what did
white do
Queen uh C5 I suppose to keep two people
defended
it's very surprising that David keeps on
playing that isn't this also just a draw
now with Rook C4 where does the White
Queen go
I have no idea where is he going to come
with again maybe he wants to put his
Queen on D2 no but after Rook C4 what
does white play
um
yeah how to get it even that I think
would be uh just a draw
Rook C4 Queen E7 rookie 4 would be a
draw by repetition
yeah but he could he could just do it
with a queen chat
or many others of course I understand
so um well we keep the camera on David
there
against uh Vincent
there we are blacks made a move
so let's remind our viewers that we
already have the winner of this event
it's alireza feroza absolutely from the
event and who got
uh the first qualification spot and we
believe that Fabiana Karan is also very
close to getting a second that's right I
think the repeating move Serana as well
don't you
it looks like rookie 4 Rook C4
and there's an Arbiter there as well
so this game
crazy five okay so it's a rook C4 one
it's about to finish
if Roxy Forest played now then it will
be Rook C4 number two
so uh that would be uh and now I mean
Central try to play for win
do you think so no sure no hopefully not
anyway over Milan to you now for an
interview yes thank you Stuart we're
joined by Jesse February who finished
her game with Alina bevel that was uh oh
my goodness yes against the
500 points higher rated player we must
say that 500 yes I didn't know I saw you
were 1857 she's like 2 307. it's
important to not look at the ratings
but but it
it was interesting that you know you had
an upper hand in that game and you were
winning so what went wrong in the end uh
I think I got into time trouble I was
actually two pawns up at some stage so I
was really comfortable
um of course there were some like
factors and and things in my head that
sort of held me back from executing a
good finish but also maybe I think it's
a lack of experience and and knowledge
in the end game so obviously it
encourages me to work on on those kind
of end games in future but overall you
played a very good game against a
significantly high rated player and
overall in these 11 days you had to face
players who are way more experienced
than uh well frankly strong stronger
stronger than you when you look at these
past 11 days what's the highlight of the
tournament for you I think I grew like
five years in in these 11 days
um no honestly as I mentioned in the
previous interview as well it's such a
pleasure and honor to be here and being
able to meet the players but also seeing
some old friends again and you're
acquainting myself it'll be nice to to
look forward to the next event I guess
it's the Olympiad
and the highlight of the tournament also
I guess is that I really really learned
from my games
as much as I'd like to say you know I
could have played better and you know I
missed some tactics and and whatever
else
beyond the analysis and the Recaps that
I've been posting I've been trying to
okay it's hard to sit down with your
loss and you know evaluate what went
wrong and I guess it's emotionally
taxing but it helps you learn but also I
mean we we need to be aware of the
context that obviously these are way
more experienced players so uh you know
have more opportunity to play than you
did so uh how difficult is it when you
sit in front of such players not to show
them too much respect
I think it's a matter of
um that's a good question because I was
going to mention it anyway it's
important to sort of see your opponent
as you equal as to not get
psychologically overwhelmed or
intimidated because then you've already
lost the game psychologically at least
and whether you are very well prepared
or whether you are not
um
it's it's almost like the game is over
before it's begun so it's important to
uh I guess not look at your opponents at
all so like for instance I don't look at
their ratings I know the player but I
like just for the sake of I know they're
higher rated I'm not gonna look at this
and then prepare yeah okay well I'm sure
that's good advice people who are uh at
that level should take up thank you very
much it's been great having you
congratulations once again thank you
thanks
yes thank you Milan and uh Jesse there
who uh did uh achieve a draw today Anna
uh but it was a shame that she didn't
win because as we saw she did have a one
game there right close to the end she
was thrill of our class doing this
game and I think her mood would have
been even better if she won the game
that's right her last game but still
after 10 losses I think uh making a draw
should be
uh should be a good result yeah at least
considered to be a good result
so um okay so uh
this game is still going on David Howe
um I don't really ends never ending I
mean um Queen's attack the queen has to
go to E7 we think to keep the B4 Pawn
defended but it's it has already been
there it's already been there and then
rookie four and it's just backwards and
forwards and that must be a three-fold
repetition if black wants it
and otherwise yeah we appreciate the
fighting spirit
but nothing is happening
he's paid Queen D5 Goodness Me David
Howe Queen D5
he wants to play after Rook takes B for
he wants to play Queen and E4 check but
he could bring the queen 22 without
sacrificing that ball
Goodness Me
Queen D5
no dinner for us no dinner for Vincent
and how old
if Rook takes B4 Anna what's he doing he
wants to play uh
he wants to play Queen D2
let's say he wants to play no sorry no
sorry I mean let's assume he wants to
play he just wants to play he wants to
play yeah but uh
is that his idea and then after okay
he wants to play
bizarre actually I find that very uh
very strange decision
would you have repeated move sir Anna
you would have done wouldn't you I'm
sure hold on that guy long ago
so if we are trying to build some real
Fortress and then check without
just any chances
remarkable that David doesn't just
repeat moose
even prepared to give up a pawn in order
to keep the game somehow going but
there were only final reactions from
Winston the first time after like when
he offered the draw and then doubt
refused and then he was like what then
there was a reputation Queen and then
David played something and that means it
was like what and after Queen decided
again
you know who this reminds me of uh
Valentina grunina oh yeah you know for
example in Gibraltar as you would as you
know in the women's Grand Prix it's
doing anything rather than make a draw
but she lost some of the games in this
manner
the game she lost against
uh as if there's something wrong with
making a draw when the position is
completely drawn
uh he can't believe it
oh where is my chicken where's my
chicken
how long should I sit here
that's just a remarkable decision from
David it really is
let's just go back to that's the
position that we are look at Vincent now
Queen D5 David has less time he's
something like three minutes to go until
the um
well he's only three moves from the time
control
Queen D5 allowing black to take
this Pawn on B4
and the only reason can be the move
Queen D2
but um
it just makes uh
is there any price for the longest game
in this tournament
uh for the game or
you have made the
hard to say
the highest number of moves of moves or
yeah
um the longest game by time
price for the fighting spirit
well
I mean Vincent doesn't have to take that
opponent before he can just play with
like King H7 and then David will have to
play
something like Queen D2
and we're sort of back where we were
before
but if you can take a pawn without
almost no danger
those are the games we should come back
also to look at that game between
shugirov and Nikita vichugov
down on board nine that was uh
interesting and all the other games
there have been drawn yes so but
fighting games I would say yeah
only one game finished too quickly yeah
Alexander's game all the others who are
really fighting yeah that's right and
quite exciting I would say uh well in
the women's section there are many
decisive games
shall we also check quickly on the
kita's game Anna
which we think is still in progress
one of those top 10 games
and wow
I would say this is more interesting
yeah more interesting let's calculate
where did we leave it and what's
happened
uh we are left after uh Rook D1 F5
then Bishop D2 was played Queen to d8
Bishop is three came to F6 Rook to C1
and queen 26. this is the current
position
foreign
so um
yeah so white has a rook and Bishop for
queen
Black's King is uh in
some Danger
but maybe it's not as bad as it was for
black it looks uh
it looks better than it looks better
than it did a while ago certainly yeah
now the queen came back
the king is uh in less danger I would
say because For the Kill only 600 this
bishop my white skin can also be in
danger black trying to open the e-file
though yeah
and um
white down to five minutes inside five
minutes which move number are they on um
46 they are far away far away from the
time control it moves 60.
so uh
this the I mean anything could happen
here but white has less time yeah
yeah uh this down on material as well
so um important moment so they're
playing of course for uh for good prize
money
then a chance for Grand Prix place for
today and Nikita
they are on six out of ten so if they
win
well unfortunately I'm
probably not I don't know
certainly a good price though
some small chances are underrated like
that and maybe even a chance of a Grand
Prix place here
so it's
um
it's white to play and he's down to
inside four minutes now
should get off
to play a lot of moves I know we said 14
moves will say
so what can I suggest here
yeah I don't know let's see
I really don't know what one should do
far we play
let's say Bishop C5
Queen F4 I want to make a draw already
Bishop C5 okay yeah Queen E5 I thought
of
Rook D1
with the idea of Bishop D4 okay
or if Queen F4 and Bishop D4 check here
is winning isn't it oh sorry yeah I like
Bishop C5 yeah
so if uh Queen E5 uh
I thought about that
um there may even be a better move than
that but okay uh which one I don't know
yeah I see Queen B2 check is this red I
didn't see that
Vincent has not taken that pawn on B4
and how about that he played rookie four
okay rookie four
foreign
he doesn't want this idea with F3 to
happen at all and maybe okay well let's
let's show this spectacular game uh
maybe he just wants to go for rookie six
and there is no F3 it just prevents f2f3
it feels like he's already a bit angry
who's that Vincent you think Vincent's
angry
hmm
yeah hungry
I think he's more Angry than hungry
Rook E4 surprising he didn't take that
pawn though
it's understandable I mean the rookie 4
is much more understandable than all
these Queen maneuvers
just saying okay here I am what you
gonna do
Queen back to D2 we've been here before
then black will move his King I suppose
or play rookie six rather
you think Anna
to prevent F3
I Rook F6 to E6
is he going to do it
and then what queen G5
that's right 28
yeah he's played it okay at least
Vincent's strategy I can understand
a little look he's looking at his uh up
at David there as well
foreign
they're about to get to move 60.
and then David guess what they get an
extra 15.
minutes don't remind me about that
there we go let's move to Nikita's Camp
happy to move back to Nikita's game if
you'd like
uh okay I talked about that more work A7
yeah the idea okay to take only six but
I wasn't sure what's happening if uh
okay A7
right
or not
okay dtxaphorical side is a Checkmate I
thought about after X E4
and then I was a bit uh word for the
skin David has played would you show us
to check my channel after DTX E4
Rook check
on a nice Checkmate Checkmate very nice
very nice well done okay next line it's
a f takes E4
right and if Rook takes A6 a bit risky
this is very risk no I see
check and uh
who knows
and okay we all we even have this Rook
C8
right it's King 6 F3 possible
King six whiskey chess
Maybe
so if the four okay
G4 and the King escapes King escapes
yeah
and
okay what else if not
peructor C8 can we take on history
because the Rook on C1 is unprotected
somewhere or
what else
David Hall has played uh another movie
King back to G2
maybe Queen E5
sacrificing this one no then you take
with The Rock from like with this Rook
and we see Vincent there making her his
move as well
I don't believe there are some major
changes
so um Nikita's game is certainly
exciting
King G6 from Vincent we'll see it here
okay
preparing before
yes so Bishop D4 check I suppose
check
but very sharp
and David stands up from the board
so it means they reached more 60.
should we just catch up on that position
updates in this game so after X E4
Bishop D4 was played King G5 and F4
trying to keep the position closed
F4
kg4 okay
right
is that what he's played in the kitchen
Kings you've already played
threatening um
coin to F4 Queen takes F4 we imagine
before in fact the B4 Pawn is also
hanging
I thought about um Queen F4 Bishop E3
maybe black still has to go to C8
to defend the bishop
and then both spawns are under the
attack
okay
but the Canon G4 feels much safer than
this position you saw a couple of months
ago with the canine insects
well I agree
but it's kind of messy isn't it still uh
white has two and a half minutes now and
it's quite a lot of moves to get to the
time control so that's an exciting game
David house game is less exciting but
it's still going on
so there may be some drama um there in a
few moves we'll see about that after the
break a very quick break now from Anna
myself
and we'll be back
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with Club Arenas you can
Club Arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chess variants and with any starting
position you want Club Arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
[Music]
foreign
to play chess online or learn how to
improve join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
hundreds of thousands of people playing
at any moment you'll quickly find a game
with someone at your level whether
you're a total beginner or a Grandmaster
you can play games at any Pace against
friends other members or one of our many
computer personalities
chess.com makes improving fun and easy
sharpen your game with tactics puzzers
and enhance your strategy with our
videos and lessons by top Masters learn
from your own games with chess.com's
easy to use analysis tool regardless of
your skill level chess.com has all you
need to take your game to the next level
chess.com is your go-to source for chess
News live coverage of tournaments events
and everything in between
experiencechess.com anytime and anywhere
whether you're at home on your computer
or on the go with our mobile apps
signing up is free and easy so what are
you waiting for join chess.com today
and welcome back everyone here live I'm
Stuart Conquest with me Anna music and
we're here on day 11 the final day of
the feed hs.com Grand Swiss and women's
Grand Swiss we have a winner of the open
his alireza ferrugia
but we still have some games here uh in
progress Anna and this is a very
exciting one it's you get off-white
versus indicator vichigov
and look at that black king on G4 Bishop
D1 the last move
and both players are in time trouble as
well I believe which move number are
they on 51 51 they have to get to move
60.
uh before they get an additional 15
minutes
so it's not the final day it's
time
we'll be accommodating on it in honor of
Mikhail yeah indeed
and uh
anniversary 18 yes 80th anniversary of
the of the day after the blitz would be
it would have been his birthday
and um we'll be here to commentate Anna
tomorrow
so um lots to look forward to there so
uh and yeah nine round nine double
rounds so 18 rounds 18 hours and they're
playing three minutes plus two seconds
increments enter Fabian is going to play
and fabi's gonna play yeah it's not on
the list of the participants yet but he
told us uh that after the game he
decided what he said yeah and David Howe
I know wants to play as well but he'll
have to finish this game first
um
so uh what do we think black should play
here under Bishop D1 from shiger off and
wow it's complete Mayhem a complete
contrast with the
with David's game
you see some difference
I don't know what's going on here
what is going on
um the problem is that the check
maybe it's not even the threat like in
E1 or kid F1 will be made by E2 right
so so if we take
Queen takes before
just to take something
um Sean is Rook takes C6 possible or not
no then the queen D2
oh I see and check them out no yeah it's
possible you're right here of course
so it threatens Queen D2 check hmm
what's wrong with that
what is wrong with that move it looks uh
it looks good isn't it
Queen takes B4 we just Bishop Bishop E3
Bishop takes E3 I think yes
threatening F1 or Kinder three wow what
a position most H4 of course there is
okay seven check mate
Nikita down to about two and a half
minutes white has about a minute left
with plenty of moves to be played yeah I
agree Queen takes before Bishop takes E3
so maybe
maybe white should be more uh black
should be more careful
um what about Queen E6 Queen E4 idea
Queen E6 attacking the white Rook I'm
just suggesting some
if this all right Queen E4 then attacks
G2 as well
that looks good
that does look very strong I have to say
Queen E6
followed by Queen E4 so let's say what
takes we take conjure to check
it to check
well
the game to end with no shouldn't be
good for black
King F3 Roxy strike in F4
if the king can escape it looks sure
then King E4
and uh bishopsy took him before District
4x6 can be four would be freaking King
runs all the way through oh actually
it's unclear
also King takes F4 maybe this I can text
maybe we should have taken an F4
before making all that because like this
this this
and maybe it's a drug in a five rocket
stream
so uh after
moved here no he's not going inside a
minute as well
to make a lot of moves if we just take
a rook check if Fork Chuck King this
tree which move did he play on I think
something's happened
he played no sorry he played King H5
King H5 he played
wow
King H5
not what we were thinking of if King D3
or Bishop is three now
okay Bishop B3 now D4
why it has played a move
yeah both players have to play Fast
they've had almost no time left
about a minute to move or 30 Seconds To
Move It was Rook it's Rook H7 came to G4
so if we're Capstone we get the same
position
maybe what's happy with the job but
black could certainly try other things
let's see what white does
presumably he's going to play Rook F7
Nana
we can try with rugby
so that Queen is seven queen of six
doesn't come you know
with the temple but of course we have to
consider than a queen to F4
let's play the move for today I don't
know why
I know they repeat it
was played
again King H5 so it looks like what
you're not clever George
maybe the players are going to
repeat moves
after an absolutely incredible fight I
have to say that we didn't follow this
game moved by move but from what we've
seen of it
looked very exciting indeed maybe white
was winning yeah we thought white had a
good position
uh a little bit earlier earlier
in this game yes yeah
it looks like there should have been
something
it doesn't look like other players claim
to draw though okay now with Rook F7 uh
White can claim
yeah it's an opposite of standing there
as well
oh no he's done something else
did you take on E3
I'm not sure
I think he's played something else
Fighting Chess yeah absolutely
what did white play or did he just
repeat moves
crazy position he took only three wow
extremely Brave move
this is move I'll move number 55 is it
yes 55. but Nikita's built his time up
getting 30 seconds to move there
repeating
moves
King Park is a force he's gained a bit
of time on the clock he's now down he's
got two and a half minutes now
nice game yeah amazing game
so if D4 or
let's try D4
King somewhere check King F1
and then what
foreign
doing well now
a rook of seven kidney sex Bishop
history Bishop D5 hmm
yeah because seven that's right
King E6
really crazy position here with no time
left as well for either player
absolutely any result is possible here
Bishop takes E3 was the last move played
yeah he hasn't played D4 yet
that's the position
looks like he's played D4 do you think
if we play King F5
kind of our list there's a check yeah
he played D4 he played D4 okay
white down to 30 seconds to make a reply
it's probably moved his King somewhere
discover check
foreign
of course now what's white going to play
Bishop D2
the black should be a
should be doing well
he's played something
if roxifier black takes yeah
tax is preparing a rock of 17 is six
Bishop B3 because
[Music]
incredible F6 unbelievable game
Rook takes C6
look at that one and a half minutes each
last round
and a lot of prize money at stake here
yeah both of these players on six out of
ten the moment
we'll take C6 so let's have a quick look
at if Queen takes C6 Rook F7 check
if King E4 Bishop F3 check wins the
queen
so if here then there is a check
King E6 uh three
oh yes Queen C4 check then after tax
takes very nice
seven
takes takes
well
yeah
what do you think
the heat hasn't moved yet
no he's done something
I guess he's played King E6 now yeah
King six Bishop B3
okay a few quick moves
I think Queen yeah Queen C4 has been
played it's been played right okay yeah
good okay check check
and now another check
and after all this who stands better
yeah after all this it's move 60 so they
get additional 15 15 minutes
no it's move 60. oh it's more 60. okay
um we've seen the kids
yeah we did it
[Laughter]
and uh
after all this it may yet
end in the draw this game
but what a game incredible unbelievable
position Now with uh Black's King all
these checks and double checks
or discover checks rather
meanwhile David Howell is still playing
that
um
in the other games that we've been uh we
kind of pretend we don't yeah we
remember about
let's have a quick look at David's game
see if anything is happening now
I'm sure it's a good idea let's have a
quick look come on we have to uh
keep up with this
has anything much happened or not
uh
um
and it's the current position is that
the current position it's the current
position
and so they got to the term control I
have I have a great idea
tell me look
we are making a three angel
here and with the triangle G2
and Canon H6 we push F3 and then after
rookies three we have kinf2
I see
what's good brother
show me maybe it was even more tricky to
start with King G1
I think this was more precise what's the
plan the plan is to meet King H6 with F3
and after Rook is really we have kind of
two and our King is closer to the center
than black skin right that would be uh
what would happen then
uh still after F4 Maybe
and uh King to just
accepts uh King to F5 no but here uh
White can try with Queen D5 and 25.
and if Rook E2 just the spawn end game
so kind of plan for white bring his King
to Q2 and play F3 kind of a plan
but it may be losing for white this kind
of plan
I mean even if white weights there is
this G6 weight anymore sure G6 and in
fact
doesn't work does it
but in the current position
um
Well Repair the king G2 and he went back
to H2
but it will black and black in H7 or
kinet six uh well here kinetics of
course F3 black just take
and there is absolutely no idea
hmm
and this is um
which move number
64. 64.
no polls on the result of this game I
know
please no
look at Vincent there
we already have the standings in the
women's tournament okay late in late in
Chia the winner of the event uh Lizzie
is second and Susan or third my sister
Force
sevens
then Alexandra costanuk 8 and teleport 9
and baby Sarah surbava it's got tens
place
get in the norm and the title and the GM
and the title qualifying to the Grand
Prix as well the finishing second I'm
winning a very good prize winning very
good price
there we are those are the women's
prizes first price twenty thousand
pounds goes of course the lateing G
and then second sixteen and a half
thousand third fourteen thousand Etc
right the way down to two twentieth
Place winning two thousand I think
they're sharing the price I assume
they're showing the same with the same
points so Elizabeth will have to share
her prize with this General
and there we see um
the game that we can't let go of David
against for instance the game that keeps
us
stay in here
and
if either player were to win he reaches
seven and a half points
which would tie for second place with
Fabiano caruana and Gregory operin
so
extremely unlikely we think the game
doesn't end a draw but if it did not end
the draw then either player reaches um a
tie for second
so far eight draws on the top 10 boards
but only one game added in relatively
a quick
drawn against Alexander it was
theoretically a theoretical variation
yes uh between a crochet variation but
the true
but ended in a draw all the other games
were all fighting games and quite long
games for example uh fabiana's game was
really interesting it was indeed
it was a very good and also maximum
great game
very exciting
um
okay
we could always have another look at the
sort of the
q a sound has been playing I was going
to say maybe the sharp uh the sharpest
moments the key moments from one or two
of those games such as Maxim's game
well um
this game is still in progress Nikita's
game is sort of reached to Karma
moments
look at that nine out of 11 for later
performance
wonderful results and once again
congratulations to late in Gia for
winning this tournament and qualifying
to the candidates
and uh there we have the other points
there so Olga won her game did she she
must have won she won't let him against
Daisy Curry
and Alexander kosnik drawing
so um
this game I don't know what you think of
uh shook it off against the two gov now
I did exercise three has been played and
now
Roxy 4.
androxy 4 has been played right
why it's king ready to come to E2
if King D5 then Rook C5 check I suppose
then Brenda came to eat and the King
sweet too of course yeah
it's a bit better for white
but likely to end in a draw I agree
David playing the mysterious King H1
I can see
do you have any favorite games in this
event I know we've seen so many it's
hard now isn't it to sort of uh remember
all of them
or any highlights or special moments uh
no I remember quite many of them but to
name my favorite one
uh maybe maybe I would say Alexander
practice uh the Queen's sacrifice yeah
it was very special wasn't it
not only the queen sacrifice but also
then how he attacked a
even with some silent moves so it wasn't
very straightforward not very direct
yeah true
um
well many many great games of course
that we've seen and uh
yeah Corona's game yeah
this 95 sacrifice also Sheriff's 95
sacrifice against oddly
I think it's ugly correct yeah
and also the games that meant that sort
of decided this event such as um
fabiana's win over
um alireza very important for the final
standings
big fights and um
very important victory for Fabiano
so um
and in the women's event we've just seen
that one player dominate the fields
really lady
with um
a fantastic result for her 2800 plus
performance at least
a day or two ago I think she must have
finished with that kind of performance
as well
King D5 there
from Nikita
probably Rook C5 check yeah Roxy Five
are likely the most logical more in this
position
there'll be our final standings in the
open events alireza as we've said
already eight points out of 11. I think
they are not final they are not finally
well
I suppose not here
because David's still playing of course
that would be if the ghost games are
drawn I think Anna yeah yes if the
remaining two games are drawn
if David draws his game and if this uh
sugar versus vitukov withdrawal as well
as
we think it may well be now
those would be the final standings
King H1 from David what do you think is
uh any ideas there
um I don't know
not really
and what about this game King D4 King D4
all right if uh King E2 I think
or graphite can we do that
sounds like Rook CS6
[Music]
5 on the left David against uh Vincent
and I don't know maybe taking this one
should get off against which you go on
the right
are there other games still going on in
the tournament
on some of the other balls
some other board Alexander gratkin is
still playing okay all right
she's got black here and hey well she
might win a second game here yeah
yesterday she won
she won her first game in this
tournament and this one she's a pawn up
right
yeah if she starts uh
E5 yeah
this this ought to be winning I think
and then Knight E4
all right and then Knight F6 Maybe
for Bishop CS6
well we can
just play or just can't text you phone
why not I thought uh taken okay we can
also yeah take
I wanted you now to keep the kingdom F4
okay I think we can also do it this way
and then all right well this is before
then well it was before we actually have
to be careful but my idea is to bring
the king to E5 then Knight C4 Knight F5
okay I'm sure if she has the guess the
timing right then she'll win this
yeah but okay E4 is not the best not the
most technical move
maybe it's still winning
but you shouldn't rush with that
um well actually she actually won she
won already
okay good finish for Alexa so she won
the last two games
yeah the tournament didn't go so well
for her but but in that she managed to
win very good
very good okay so what else do we have
we have
this okay it's a draw
right with uh
with Rook before with almost any move
okay and you have to check from the side
this one
a player from Madagascar the only white
International master in the tournament
any winning chances it looks like a draw
because this bishop is controlling
everything
just everything
so if white plays King E5
yeah this is the only chance then Bishop
C2 Maybe
um
King F7
um Bishop f8
and then bring the spawn here right
so maybe just uh but this then again
how should black draw this game
maybe bishop H7
mm-hmm
but then I don't really need to
or do I
yeah maybe I need to
Play Bishop C to otherwise D5
that was what I was worried about that
wipers D5 area so if I bring
seven and then to after this I play this
and bring the bishop to G8 and this
should be a draw this looks like a draw
and then just skip the bishop on F7 and
G8 and white can do nothing correct yeah
uh but if
okay if can you check them here yeah
this bishop a sound Bishop jet maybe an
important maneuver hmm
kindly six then King F7 I think it's
also important that you have this one
okay it is to win the poll
white can make it uh to move the pawn to
D5 then the king to D6 so it should be
winning for white
yeah because then Bishop C3 defends the
um g-pawn yeah
all right
D2 was played Bishop sephoria black is
just waiting
okay
maybe one final look at those two games
Anna the two games that we can see on
camera there
um we've also about this to talk about
the GM Norms um in the women's section
um well non-plus title for Elizabeth as
we've said earlier and it's usually now
from China I think it's her second GM
Norm yeah
um and uh Laila yavakisfili with the GM
Norm I'm not sure if that's her title
or not I think she needs to get to 2500.
Kazakhstan
so um
and maybe some I am Norms as well I
think as well
were also achieved
um Daisy Corey I think made an I am Norm
vantika from India
and it looks like jolanta is a vachka
and Leia
from Russia
so congratulations to all these girls no
Norms achieved in the open section
because we have 107 Grand Masters there
only this gentleman here from Madagascar
gentlemen could make it but
but I think he has no chances
um should we have a very quick look just
at these two
games here before we leave
um
projected standing sorry if David Hull
makes a draw and Vincent if they draw
that game which we really think they're
going to then uh and the other game is
John
then those will be the uh standings
already the winner of this event right
and then Fabiano will be second and
krikorio parent
finishing on the third place
so there we see um on the small diagram
there on the screen we can see that
David house gave nothing much just
happens he's played King F1
and the last I think we saw this
position two two years ago two hours ago
and um Nikita also
a fairly level Rook ending
can we see that position now or not just
quickly please uh this one no sorry it
was the analysis and Rook C5 has been
specified it's been played already
expected pretty level
um also tomorrow Anna we have something
very special a blitz event Blitz events
which will be dedicated to 85th
Anniversary of mihaltal right so
we are all waiting for you to come
tomorrow but please pay attention to the
fact that the blitz tournament will
start earlier three hours earlier than
usual so the tournament starts at 11. 11
o'clock 11 A.M local time what is
actually 10 a.m Central European Time
right and um yeah so most of the top
players we think will be playing yeah
and men will play with women so there
will be no separate tournament for women
but there will be prizes for the best
female purchases 18 rounds and as a nine
double rounds three minutes plus two
seconds per player per game so lots of
excitement
to come tomorrow and we'll be here to
talk you through that and uh
we'll have some more interviews we hope
and videos and so on so um a lot of fun
a lot of fun yeah a lot of fun tomorrow
maybe you and I maybe we'll have a bliss
game Monster as well I know we'll see we
could have a Blitz game maybe maybe if
you'd like maybe if you like maybe we
will fight
thanks for watching thank you for
watching very much
thanks to our team so same team same
place just a different time we are
hoping to see you tomorrow at 10 A.M
centrally about time thanks for watching
welcome welcome everyone this is the
speed chess championship finals going
down here with Carlson and Nakamura
the bullet portion comes to an ending
car Nakamura is mathematically
eliminated in his chances and the bottom
line is Magnus Carlson shows why he is
the Magnus Carlsen
it has been hikaru's speech test
championship this 2018 and Wesley so had
an amazing event this year as well and
we were tied heading into bullet before
akaranakamura separated himself in the
final portion
I think blunder is his rook and it's
just things are just not going well for
Wesley they traded back and forth
Landing heavy blows but ultimately the
heavyweight matchup is going to go
towards akaranakamura's favor
hey Cara will be winning his third in a
row extremely impressive display once he
actually faced a deficit he has looked
like the best a car we've seen
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]